PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WILL COME TO ORDER
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVE IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS. AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE LIMITED MEMBERS
ADMITTED MEMBERS RATHER OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY. TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 877-336-4437 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT TWO SIX
EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO MORE
EXPERTISE REFERRED TO THE
SENATE WEBSITE OR OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT
TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTE. AND
YOU WILL THEN BE READY TO
ADDRESS THIS COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU WERE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE I'LL REPEAT THAT. YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU WERE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY. OVER THE
PHONE. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND NEW CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEES WILL
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY ACCORDINGLY EACH SIDE
WILL ONLY BE PERMITTED THE
TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES. ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME. THEIR AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURES. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL BE MAINTAINING
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY HERE IN THE SENATE
AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE. OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HIRING
PROCESS AND THE CONDUCTOR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER. AS IS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO WERE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE. OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES SO. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO THAT
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES MAY BE
HEARD. WE HAVE FIFTEEN BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE HAS BEEN PULLED FROM OUR
AGENDA. WE HAVE ONE MEASURE
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
FIVE SEVEN THREE. AND FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
FOUR THREE WE'LL BE TESTIMONY
ONLY TODAY. QUESTIONS FROM
COLLEAGUES IN THE CHAMBER WILL
BE HELD UNTIL A FURTHER
PROCEEDINGS. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS WE
WILL NOT ESTABLISH A QUORUM WE
WILL OPERATE AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
AND THE FIRST ITEM TODAY IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM. THANK YOU
SIR YOU MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR
NEXT BILL OR YOUR BILL ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE TWO EIGHT TWO WHEN YOU
ARE READY THANK YOU I HAD THAT
IS- FILE ORDER NUMBER ONE SO
MAYBE I GOT THE NUMBERS IN
REVERSE BUT TO BE CLEAR- THE-
BILL THAT I'M- PROCEEDING ON
TODAY'S AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO.
THE CALIFORNIA PET BLOOD
MODERNIZATION ACT AND THE BILL
THAT'S BEING REMOVED AS AB ONE
OH THREE FOUR. THAT IS CORRECT
THANK THANK YOU MR CHAIR AT THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FIRST
LET ME THANK. BNP AND ACT
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING
CLOSELY WITH MY OFFICE ON THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE DEVELOPED IN
COLLABORATION WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. WE'VE MADE GREAT
STRIDES TOWARDS RESOLVING THE
REMAINING ISSUES IN THE BILL
WITH THEIR HEALTH. EIGHTY
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO THE
CALIFORNIA PET BLOOD BANK
MODERNIZATION ACT SEEKS TO
ADDRESS BOTH THE SHORTAGE OF
ANIMAL BLOOD FOR VETERINARY
TRANSFUSION MEDICINE. HAND THE
OBSOLETE IN HUMANE AND
ULTIMATELY LIMITING PRACTICE OF
CAPTIVE CLOSED COLONY CANINE
BLOOD BANKS IN CALIFORNIA. THE
BILL AUTHORIZES LICENSED
VETERINARIANS TO OPERATE
COMMUNITY BLOOD BANKS THAT
PRODUCE AND SELL ANIMAL BLOOD
AND BLOOD PRODUCTS. THESE
COMMUNITY BLOOD BANKS FOR
ANIMALS ARE SIMILAR TO HUMAN
MODELS IN THAT THEY COLLECT
BLOOD FROM PETS WHOSE ONERS
VOLUNTARILY CONSENT TO THE
DONATION. CURRENTLY THIS
VOLUNTARY COMMUNITY BASED
APPROACH ISN'T ALLOWED HERE. IN
FACT CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY
STATE IN THE COUNTRY THAT
REQUIRES ANIMAL BLOOD TO COME
FROM SO CALLED CLOSED COLONIES
THAT KEEP HUNDREDS OF ANIMALS
IN CONFINEMENT FOR YEARS. FOR
THE SOLE PURPOSE OF HARVESTING
THEIR BLOOD. THERE HAVE ONLY
EVER BEEN TO AN EIGHTIES THAT
HAVE OPERATED SUCH A BUSINESS
IN CALIFORNIA. AND MEANWHILE
DEMAND FOR ANIMAL BLOOD VASTLY
OUTSTRIPS THIS CLOSE CALL IN
THE SUPPLY AND VETERINARIANS
ARE REGULARLY FACED WITH A LACK
OF LIFE SAVING PRODUCTS TO
PERFORM TRANSFUSIONS. AND
RESPOND TO EMERGENCIES. AB
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO PROVIDES A
HUMANE SOLUTION FOR SOURCING
ANIMAL BLOOD WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY ADDRESSING THE
SUPPLY SHORTAGE AND
ESTABLISHING CONDITIONS TO
EVENTUALLY PHASE OUT CAPTIVE
CLOSE CALL IN THE CANINE BLOOD
BANKS. AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
ADDRESSES THE GOVERNOR'S TWENTY
NINETEEN VETO OF SB TWO OH TWO
BY PROVIDING A TRANSITION AWAY
FROM THE USE OF CAPTIVE CLOSE
CALL IN THE CANINE BLOOD BANKS
IN CALIFORNIA. ONLY PHASING
THEM OUT ONCE THE AMOUNT OF DOG
BLOOD COMMUNITY BANK SELL
EQUALS OR EXCEEDS THE AMOUNT
THE CLOSE CALL ON THE CELL. OF
FOUR CONSECUTIVE QUARTERS THIS
IS AN ISSUE THAT SENATOR WELL
CAN I HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
PASSIONATELY FOR THE PAST THREE
YEARS AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS THE APPROACH THAT
VETERINARIANS ANIMAL WELFARE
INTERESTS IN THE AFFECTED STATE
DEPARTMENTS CAN ALL AGREE WILL
PUT CALIFORNIA ON A PATH TO AN
ETHICALLY SOURCED SAFE AND
EXPANDED. ANIMAL BLOOD SUPPLY.
EARLIER THIS MONTH AB TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO PASSED OUT OF THE
SENATE AGRICULTURAL COMMITTEE
WITH UNANIMOUS SUPPORT. IN THE
MOST RECENT SET OF AMENDMENTS
TO AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
CONSISTENCE AND TECHNICAL COOK
CORRECTIONS OR CONFORMING
AMENDMENTS BUT ALSO PROVIDED
SIMPLIFIED SOLUTIONS TO THE
LAST OUTSTANDING SUBSTANTIVE
ISSUE AND THIS INCLUDES
IMPROVING THE TRIGGER FOR WHEN
WE WILL TRANSITION AWAY FROM
CLOSE COLONIES. CALLING IN TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THIS MORNING ARE DR JEANINE
BERGER SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF
RESCUE AND WELFARE AT THE SAN
FRANCISCO SPCA. AND DR DEV MORE
EIGHT EIGHT CRITICAL LIST AT
INSIGHT VENTURE MERRY WELLNESS
CENTER IN EL DORADO HILLS.
WITNESSES PLEASE PROCEED.
WARNING THAT THE CHAIR AND
MEMBER. FOR I MEAN YOU CAN HEAR
ME CLEARLY WE CAN HEAR YOU
PERFECTLY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MY NAME IS DR JEANINE BERGER
AND I AM A LICENSED CALIFORNIA
VETERINARIAN AND THE SENIOR
VICE PRESIDENT. OF RESCUE AND
ANIMAL WELFARE FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO SPCA. THE DAVID I'M
BOARD CERTIFIED WITH THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF VETERINARY
BEHAVIORISTS. AS WELL AT THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF ANIMAL
WELFARE. TWO THOUSAND AND
ELEVEN I HAVE OVERSEEN ALL
ASPECTS OF CLINICAL BEHAVIOR
AND WELFARE PROGRAM AT THE SAN
FRANCISCO SPCA. I URGE YOUR
HIGH VOTE AT TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
MODERNIZE CALIFORNIA. ANIMAL
BLOOD BANKS DESTRY.
VETERINARIAN AND THE PUBLIC ARE
INCREASINGLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE WELFARE STATUS OF ANIMALS
IN SOCIETY THESE CHANGES HAVE
IMPACTED MOLD AREA A GREAT MANY
PRACTICE INCLUDING THE CANINE
BLOOD BANKING INDUSTRY. DID
CURRENT SITUATION IN CALIFORNIA
IS THE GREEK JUSTLY ON BALANCE.
BLOOD DON'T KNOW DOGS ARE KEPT
CONFINED FOR MONTHS OR YEARS IN
APPALLING CONDITIONS. FOR
COMPLETE IN A MOVE THAT. IN
NEED ON MANY BLOOD BANKS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY TRANSACTION FROM
COLD CALLING THE PROGRAM A
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAM THAT
COLLECTS BLOOD FROM PRE GREEN
HEALTHY FAMILY PATH WITH HIS
FAMILY AND SUCCESSFUL PROTOCOLS
IN PLACE. HOW AREA OKAY THE
NECESSARY EDUCATION AND SKILLS
TO MODERNIZE INDUSTRIES IN WAYS
THAT ARE PRACTICAL FATE AND YOU
MAY. WE ARE EAGER TO WORK
TOGETHER OUR PROFESSION TO MAKE
COMMUNITY BLOOD BANK THE
STANDARD OF CARE AND THE COLD
COLONY BLUFFING. TRANSACTION TO
COMMUNITY SOURCING. HE CA HAD
TO BE TO COLLECT BLOOD BUT
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW MUST
CURRENTLY OUT THE FRAMEWORK
THAT BALANCES THE INTERESTS AND
WELL BEING OF DONOR ANIMALS
RECIPIENT ANIMAL AND MARION WHO
NEED ACCESS. TO A HEALTHY BLOOD
SUPPLY. WE DON'T NEED BANK CAN.
SAFELY PRACTICALLY PRACTICALLY
WE ARE OPTIMISTIC THAT WE CAN
SORT OUT THE FINAL UNRESOLVED
ISSUES INCLUDING THIS CLEAR AND
SAFE TRIGGER FOR SIGNALING THE
PATIENT SAFE BLOOD AND BLOOD
PRODUCTS FROM HUMAN RESOURCES
AND DEVELOPMENT OKAY HELPFUL
BEST PRACTICES. EIGHT TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO BALANCE THE WELFARE
BENEFITS TO THE DONOR AND THE
RECIPIENT ANIMALS AND I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU THE NEXT WITNESS
MOST OF THE THREE MINUTES WAS
USED UP SO ONE MINUTE PLEASE.
HI GOOD MORNING- CHAIRMAN ROB
DAY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. OF AB TWELVE
EIGHTY TO HELP INCREASE S. AND
ASSURE THAT ADEQUATE SAFE
SUPPLY OF CANINE BLOOD.
VETERINARY NEEDS IN CALIFORNIA.
MY NAME IS DR DEBORAH MAUREEN
I'M A BOARD CERTIFIED EMERGENCY
AND CRITICAL CARE VETERINARIAN
PRACTICING FOR OVER TWENTY NINE
YEARS IN CALIFORNIA. HI HOW
SEEN A DRAMATIC INCREASE IN THE
NEED FOR BLOOD PRODUCTS OVER
THE YEARS I'VE HAD PARENTS
DEMAND ABOUT CARE FOR THEIR
DOGS. ARE THE CONSEQUENCE IT IS
NOW COMMON THE BLOOD TO BE
UNAVAILABLE OR IN SHORT SUPPLY
IN TIMES OF NEED. ACTUATION
HOME FOR ME LAST FALL WHEN MY
PARENTS DOG NEEDED MULTIPLE
UNITS OF BLOOD AFTER A
COMPLICATED SURGERY. WE USE OUR
OWN SMALL SUPPLY AND THEN
SCRAMBLED TO BAR THE RAP THAT
WE NEEDED FROM ALL OVER THE
AREA. SECONDLY DEPLETING THE
AREA BLOOD SUPPLY FOR THE
WEEKEND AND WHILE I'M HAPPY
THAT PART GOES THERE BY THE
PAID ME TO THINK OF THE DOG. I
MAY NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
RECEIVE THE BLOOD THEY NEED TO
DO TO LIMITED SUPPLY. I'VE BEEN
ON THAT END OF THE SITUATION
TOO MANY TIMES BEING FORCED TO
MAKE DIFFICULT DECISIONS ABOUT
WHICH PATIENT I CAN HELP. WITH
A LIMITED BLOOD SUPPLY. I
STRONGLY YOU TO. A B. TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO WHICH WILL ALLOW
CALIFORNIA VETERINARIAN TO JOIN
THE REST OF THE NATION AND
ESTABLISHING COMMUNITY BASED
FLOOD BANKS. AND SAFELY
INCREASE OUR BLOOD SUPPLY AND
HELP MORE CRACKS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU BOTH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
JUST SAY THIS BEFORE I TURNED
TO THE GALLERY WE HAVE AFAIRLY
LENGTHY AGENDA TODAY AND WE
HAVE TO CLEAR THIS ROOM FOR
OTHER COMMITTEES AT AN
APPROPRIATE TIME THAT SHORTER
RATHER THAN LONGER SO I'M GOING
TO HAVE TO ASK ANY WITNESSES
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO TRY TO TIGHTEN
UP. THE COMMENTS AND
PARTICULARLY THOSE CONTINUING
AT THIS POINT VISIT NAME
POSITION NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ONLY IF WE CAN
POSSIBLY MANAGE THAT TURNING TO
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY FIRST
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT WE
HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION HERE. MA'AM PLEASE
SERVICE PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR THE
RECORD THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE MISTER CHAIR AND
CHRISTINA KAHRL REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA VETERINARY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION WITH A
TWEENER POSITION OF A PROOF.
JUST WANTED TO TAKE A TWO
SECONDS TO THANK MR BLOOM AND
HIS TEAM FOR THEIR AMAZING
LEADERSHIP IN THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS THAT WAS VERY
INCLUSIVE. AND PRODUCTIVE AND
THANK A LIST OF SILVER OF YOUR
COMMITTEE FOR BRINGING US ALL
TOGETHER ON THE PRODUCT IT IS
BEFORE YOU TODAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. OTHER WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY IN SUPPORT WITH
BACK TO THIS MEASURE. YES GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JENNIFER FEARING HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO
HUMANE SOCIETY I TOO WANT TO
THANK YOUR STAFF. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
ASSEMBLY BILL. TWELVE EIGHTY
TWO. SEEING NONE LET'S TURN TO
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE A
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE EIGHTY
TWO. I SEE NO SUCH WITNESSES SO
NOW LET'S MOVE TO THE-
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR FEUD PLEASE PROMPT
ANY SUCH WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE WE WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO PRESS ONE AND ZERO.
IF YOU WISH TO EXPRESS SUPPORT.
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE. FIFTY
THREE. GOOD MORNING KAREN
NUMBER THREE FORTY DOLLARS ON
BEHALF OF THE HUMANE SOCIETY OF
THE UNITED STATES AND THE
CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINE
FORTY SEVEN. HI- CAN YOU HEAR
ME. FINALLY PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU THIS IS JUDY MAN CREW
STILL FOUNDER PRESIDENT SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION AND
WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT ALSO
BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR YEARS
THANK YOU SO MUCH BYE BYE THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. LINE FORTY
SIX. HI MY NAME IS NICHOLA
SACKETT OF SOCIAL COMPASSION IN
LEGISLATION BUT TODAY I AM-
REPRESENTING PETER PEOPLE FOR
THE ETHICAL TREATMENT OF
ANIMALS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. LINE
TWENTY SIX. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ELIZABETH ORECK WITH BEST
FRIENDS ANIMAL SOCIETY CALLING
ON BEHALF OF OUR THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS SUPPORTERS
PARTNERS AND STAFFING AND
STRONG SUPPORT AT. EIGHTY
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. BUYING
TWENTY THREE. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS JOE PACKARD CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE AT
THAT THE ASIAN AND WE ARE
ENTHUSIASTICALLY IN SUPPORT OF.
EIGHTY TWELVE EIGHTY TWO THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. SURE
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE WOULD
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SUPPORT
WE'RE JUST GONNA DO ONE FINAL
CALL HERE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
WE HAD ONE ADDITIONAL PERSON
THAT SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK JUST A MOMENT PLACE.
AND
WE WILL NOW GO TO LINE TWENTY
SEVEN. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SHANNON
KEITH ON BEHALF OF BEAGLE
FREEDOM PROJECT IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
YEARS THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. THE TEACHER THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE COULD SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO STAY. LET'S FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS A NOTE HERE FROM
ANY OPPOSITION FIRST BEGINNING
WITH OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY. SEEING NONE LET'S
MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE.
WITNESSES WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWELVE EIGHTY TWO I SEE
NO SUCH WITNESSES. LET'S MOVE
TO THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS READY TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
WE WILL BEGIN. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THERE ARE
THIS TIME PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE FIFTY.
ONE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU YOUR FIRST STATEMENT
WAS CUT OFF A LITTLE BIT GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SEPARATELY **** ON BEHALF OF
THE ANIMAL BLOOD BANK. BLOOD
BANK IS THE FIRST AND ONE OF
ONLY TWO LICENSED VETERINARY
BLOOD BANKS IN CALIFORNIA- I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR-
SIMPLY MEMBER BLOOM AS WELL AS
SUSPENSEFUL COOPERATIVELY
NUMBER SENATOR WELL WHO ALSO
HAS A LONG HISTORY ON THIS
ISSUE. AND THE COMMITTEE STAFFS
IN BOTH HOUSES FOR THEIR GOOD
FAITH EFFORTS. TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS. FIRST THE MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS REMOVE THE REFERENCE
TO THE ASSOCIATION FOR
VETERINARIAN HEMATOLOGY
TRANSFUSION MEDICINE FOR. ME
AND AFTER THAT WE APPRECIATE IT
YES SIR SIR AT THIS POINT WE'RE
JUST TAKING NAMES. WHAT ARE YOU
THE LEADER POSITION WHICH IS
THE FIRST OPPOSITION I AM ONLY
YES OKAY YOU ARE NOT AN
AMENDMENT FOR A LONG WAY TO
YEAH. THE AMENDMENT GO A LONG
WAY TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS
REGARDING THE TRIGGER LANGUAGE
PARTICULAR WHILE WE HAD CALLED
FOR A TRIGGER BASED ON A
ROLLING THREE YEAR AVERAGE THE
AMENDMENTS. ARE PUT IN PLACE
ONE BASED ON A ONE VOLUME OVER
FOUR QUARTERS SHORTER PERIOD
BUT THE CONCEPT IS THE SAME.
RATHER CONCERN WAS THAT THE
TRIGGER. ONCE IT WAS CALLED. K.
NINE BLOOD SUPPLY WOULD FALL
OFF A CLIFF. WELL THE BILL DOES
EXTEND THE TIME. AND CALLING
THE BLOOD PRODUCTION FROM
TWELVE TO EIGHTEEN MONTHS WE
REMAIN CONCERNED. THE PEPSI
CALIFORNIA AND THEIR OWNERS
WILL NOT HAVE THE BLOOD
PRODUCTS THEY NEED AFTER THE
TRIGGER IS PULLED- WHILE A. B.
B. WOULD NEVER SUPPORTED.
INTENDED TO PUT IT OUT OF
BUSINESS. TAKE A LOOK WE- WANT
BASED ON THE FLAWED PREMISE
THAT CALLING YOU DONORS OR
ANYTHING BUT HEALTHY HAPPY AND
WELL CARED FOR. I CAN'T SAY
THAT BASED ON THESE AMENDMENTS
COMPATIBLE BLOOD BANK IS
NEUTRAL ON AB TWELVE EIGHTY
EIGHT. AND WE WILL COMMUNICATE
THAT IN WRITING TO THE AUTHOR
AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THANK
YOU AGAIN. SIMPLY MEMBER BLINK.
AND THE CREDIT. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. SURE THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE COULD SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK. OKAY WILL NOT BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE CHAMBER.
FIRST SENATOR NEWMAN FOLLOWED
BY SENATOR ARCHULETA. THANK YOU
MR CHAIR- BY WILL GLADLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL I WOULD
RIGOROUSLY ASKED. TO BE
INCLUDED AS A CO AUTHORS MOVES
FORWARD AND WHEN THE MOMENT
APPROPRIATE LIKE TO MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU SIR CENTER IT'S
A LITTLE YEAH- THANK YOU MISTER
JUST A COUPLE OF. QUESTIONS
THAT LEAD TO CALL AUTHORS WELL
I'M- GOING TO MOVE ALONG WITH
JUST A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS IS
YOUR COMPENSATION- FOR THE
OWNER. OR OR IS IT TOTALLY
VOLUNTEER AND IS THE ANIMAL
EXAMINED BEFORE. ANY BLOOD IS
DONATED. AND IS IT FINAL IS IT
JUST FOR THAT ONE CLINIC OR
DOES THE BLOOD- THAT SHE CEDED
TO DISTRIBUTED THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTY OR STATE. PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU MR CHAIR OF THE
PROGRAM IS VOLUNTARY AND I'M
SORRY THE OTHER TWO QUESTIONS-
ONCE AGAIN THAT IT WAS
VOLUNTARY THAT WAS THAT'S GREAT
AND THE- IS THE ANIMAL CHECKED
BY THE VETERINARIAN YES. I HAD
AN EXAMINATION AS TYPICAL. OKAY
AND THEN FINALLY THE BLOOD IS
IT KEPT THERE AT THAT
PARTICULAR CLINIC OR IS THE
BLOOD SENT THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTY OR THE STATE. OR JUST
FOR THAT CLINIC. FOR THAT
ANSWER I WOULD- CALL ON DOCTOR
BERGER. DOCTOR BERGER. YES YEAH
SO AT THAT POINT AND IT WILL BE
IT WILL BE DISTRIBUTED AFTER
THE FACT THAT THE COLD COLONY
BANK BLOODY CAN BE DISTRIBUTED
AT THAT LIGHT WILL BE AVAILABLE
TO VETERINARIANS THEY NEED AND-
IN A PATIENT IN. GOOD THANK YOU
THE REASON I ASK. MISS CHAIRS
BECAUSE I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S- ANIMALS ACROSS THE
BORDER GIVEN THAT EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE YOU MAY
HAVE ONE BLANK- BLOOD BANK THAT
IS EXTREMELY ACTIVE. WHILE
ANOTHER COMMUNITY ISN'T SO THAT
FRONT BUT I. WOULD LIKE TO-
MOVE THE BILL AND ALSO ASK FOR
CALL AUTHORSHIP. OKAY HANK YOU
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS CALLING SPINNER JONES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I CAME
DOWN ON THE FLOOR TODAY- IN
FULL SUPPORT HIS BILL BUT THEN
WHEN I GOT ON MY DESK I WAS
NOTICING THAT THERE'S ACTUALLY
TWO COMPANIES THAT ARE IMPACTED
BY THIS LEGISLATION. WHICH I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT- THE
LEGISLATURE. PUTTING LEGITIMATE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES OUT OF
BUSINESS SO THE- SPEAKER IN.
WHAT STARTED OFF AS OPPOSITION-
WAS INTERESTING TO ME AND I WAS
WONDERING IF THE AUTHOR COULD.
RESPOND TO THAT- THOSE COMMENTS
FROM MR LEE **** WHAT WE'RE
GRATEFUL- THAT- THE BUSINESS HE
REPRESENTS SAID HAS GONE
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL- AND THERE
THAT THIS BILL IS NOT INTENDED
TO PUT ANYONE OUT OF BUSINESS-
THE- TWO. COMPANIES THAT
CURRENTLY DO CLOSE COLONY- A
BLOOD DONOR WORK. ARE MORE THAN
WELCOME TO JOIN THE NEW SYSTEM.
AND PROBABLY WILL OKAY AND OKAY
SO I GUESS AT LEAST SET AT A
QUESTION OR A SYNERGY THAT WAS
ALLUDING TO BAN A WE GOT A
CLEAR ANSWER ON IT AND- WHEN
YOU ENROLL YOUR PET INTO THIS
PROGRAM ARE YOU COMPENSATED.
FOR WHAT YOUR PETS PROVIDING. I
GUESS IT DEPENDS ON THE TERM
COMPENSATION YOU DO RECEIVE IN
THE A TYPICAL ITERATION AS I
UNDERSTAND IT YOU RECEIVE A
FREE EXAMINATION FOR YOUR DOG-
WHICH MIGHT BE CONSIDERED SOME
FORM OF COMPENSATION- AND
USUALLY THERE'S A TREAT
INVOLVED. ABOUT ALL THAT-
DOCTOR BERGER- ADD COMMENTS OR
ANYTHING ON IT MAYBE I CAN GIVE
SOME YOU KNOW IN SOME FOR
DOCTOR BERGER YOU KNOW IF
YOU'RE SAYING THAT THAT THE TWO
COMPANIES THAT DO THIS NOW CAN
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM. I
GUESS THE BOTTOM LINE IS OUR
PROFIT- CENTER IS- PROFIT
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM IF THEY
CONTINUE TO PARTICIPATE. BUT
THE QUESTION HELLO THERE YOU
KNOW AND MONEY COMPENSATION FOR
THE DONORS BECAUSE IT'S JUST
LIKE IN HUMANS IT IS VOLUNTARY
SO IT'S THE BENEFIT TO THE
COMMUNITY BUT THEY WILL RECEIVE
AN EXAM SO WE'RE ACTUALLY.
MAKING MORE HEALTHY ANIMAL FOR
THE COMMUNITY IF THEY
PARTICIPATE AND YES I LIKE THE
TREE SO THEY DEFINITELY GET A
TREAT. AND IN ADDITION YES IT
WILL ACTUALLY PROVIDE FOR MORE
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
EVERYBODY CAN PARTICIPATE AS
SUB LIMITED TO TRIP TO
BUSINESSES THAT. ARE CURRENTLY
IN PLACE SO EVERYBODY HAS A
FAIR CHANCE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE CREATION AND THAT WE WANT
TO HAVE MORE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES. THANK YOU WELL
MISTER CHAIR BASED ON THE
TESTIMONY OF THE A MISTER LEE
**** I'LL I'LL SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY- THANK YOU. MEMBERS SO
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS. SIMPLY MEMBER BLOOM
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND-
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF ALL OF THE
DOGS WILL BENEFIT FROM A
TRANSITION TO A MORE HUMANE-
AND ROBUST SYSTEM OF- BLOOD
DONATIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM. KEITH
ROSH HERE ROSS HERE MELINDA'S
HERE MELINDA'S HERE ARCHULETA-
ARCHULETA HERE PLEASE BACKER
BACKER HERE DIED. YOUR DAUGHTER
HERE ADMIN ADMIN HERE HER TADO
JONES HERE JONES HERE LEYVA MEN
HERE MANY HERE NAME IN HERE NEW
MEN HERE AND SHOW A VOGUE HAN.
WE HAVE A QUORUM THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR NEWMAN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. VIOLATE M. Q. A B. TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO YOU DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BROTH HI. ROSS
I'M MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S I
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA I'D BEATS
BACKER. HI BACKER I. DODD. ALL
RIGHT DOT HI A MAN FIVE EIGHT
MEN I HER TADO. JONES JONES I'D
LEAVE - MAN HI MAIN HI NEWMAN.
NEWMAN I TELL ABOUT OKAY HAN.
BILL HAS NINE VOTES WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR APPOINTMENTS
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. THIS IS. SO MY
MEMBER CAREER YOU HAVE. YES TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY ONLY ON YOUR
BILL ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FOUR
THREE PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT BY
TESTIMONY ONLY EIGHTY FOUR FOUR
THREE WHICH AIMS TO CREATE A
PATHWAY TO ALLOW FOREIGN
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS AND
MEDICAL GRADUATES TO WORK IN
CALIFORNIA'S UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES TO PROVIDE. PATIENT
CARE. PATIENT CARE SUPPORT THE
REFLECTS CALIFORNIA'S
LINGUISTIC DIVERSITY THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC MADE IT CLEAR
THAT ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE IS
TRULY. A LIFE OR DATH ISSUE
ARE ESSENTIAL WORKERS IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES WERE
OVER REPRESENTED. IN NOT ONLY
CALL THE NINETEEN CASES BUT IN
MORTALITY RATES AND LONG TERM
COMPLICATIONS. THE ROOT OF
THESE OUTCOMES OUTCOME
DISPARITIES. WE TOOK GREAT
STEPS IN THE BUDGET THIS YEAR
TO GET MORE OF OUR STATE'S
RESIDENTS ACCESS TO MEDICAL.
BUT HOW USEFUL THAT B. TWO ARE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES THAT
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH PROVIDERS
AVAILABLE. ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE COMMISSION SEVEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS ALMOST ONE
IN SIX LIVE IN AN AREA WITH A
SWORD A SHORTAGE OF PROVIDERS.
THOUGH SHORTAGES ARE
CONCENTRATED IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR MAKING THE NEED FOR MULTI
LINGUAL PHYSICIANS AND EVEN
MORE ACUTE ONE. CALIFORNIA LAGS
SIGNIFICANTLY BEHIND OTHER
LARGE STATES. AND THE NATION
AND THE RATIO OF LATINO
PHYSICIANS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
TO OUR SPANISH SPEAKING
RESIDENTS. A TWENTY NINETEEN
STUDY FROM UCLA FOUND THAT
THERE WERE ONLY SIX POINT TO
LET THE KNOW PHYSICIANS
AVAILABLE FOR EVERY ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND SPANISH SPEAKING
CALIFORNIANS. FOR THE NATION
THAT WHOLE RATIO IS SIX TIMES
GREATER. THIS LAST YEAR WE HAVE
FACED A PANDEMIC AND NOW IS THE
VACCINE IS WIDELY AVAILABLE WE
HAVE SEEN HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
TO HAVE CULTURALLY. COMPETENT
POSITIONS THAT CAN BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS. WITH AND
ADVOCATE FOR COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE UNDERSERVED IN OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM REPEATED
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THE NON
ENGLISH SPEAKING PATIENTS SEE
MORE POSITIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES.
WHEN THEY'RE CARED FOR BY A
LINGUISTIC. AND CULTURALLY
COMPETENT PROVIDERS. RIGHT NOW
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH
OF THOSE PROVIDERS AVAILABLE
CREATING A PATHWAY FOR
EXPERIENCE FOR MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS AND MEDICAL
GRADUATES TO WORK WITH
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS.IN THE
LANGUAGE THAT THEY SPEAK WILL
ENSURE THAT THESE PROFESSIONALS
ARE WORKING UNDER SUPERVISION
AND THAT SUFFICIENT PATIENT
SAFEGUARDS ARE IN PLACE. AND IT
WILL HELP CLOSE THE EQUITY GAPS
IN OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE CHAIR
FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON
THIS BILL. AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO DRAFT A
FRAMEWORK THAT ACCOMPLISHES
THOSE GOALS. AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO BRINGING THIS BILL BACK TO
COMMITTEE WITH THE SUPPORT OF
THE CHAIR AND SEVERAL MEMBERS
WHO HAVE EXPRESSED SUPPORT. UP
NEXT YEAR. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SEVEN MEMBER LET'S NOW MOVE TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF YOUR
BILL FIRST ANY SUPPORT
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY.
SEEING NONE LET'S CHECK ROOM
ONE TWELVE TO SEE IF THEIR
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOUR FOUR THREE I SEE NO SUCH
WITNESSES LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FOUR THREE
WILL PROCEED. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE MIN ZERO. BUT
TO CHAIR KNOWING THE SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR LET'S KNOW.
COME BACK TO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IF THERE ARE ANY HERE
IN THE GALLERY I SEE NO SUCH
WITNESSES LET'S CHECK ROOM ONE
TWELVE WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE I SEE NO SUCH WITNESSES
ONCE AGAIN LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT AN INDIVIDUAL'S WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FOUR THREE.
WILL MOVE FORWARD. IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE ARE. SURE NO ONE HAS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
COLLEAGUES AS I MENTIONED AT
THE BEGINNING THIS IS
PRESENTATION ONLY WE WILL HOLD
OUR QUESTIONS UNTIL THIS
MEASURE BY THERE IS IT HAS IT
CURRENTLY EXISTS OR IS IT
BECOMES AMENDED COMES BACK TO
US. THE SEMI MEMBER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I AM COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH YOU AND SEVERAL OTHER
MEMBERS WHO HAVE EXPRESSED A
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE A LACK
OF DOCTORS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IMPACTS NOT ONLY
URBAN COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE BUT
RURAL AREAS WHERE FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CARE CENTERS
COULD REALLY BENEFIT FROM
HAVING ADDITIONAL DOCTORS. THAT
IS THE CONTINUED CONVERSATION
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT WE LACK PROVIDERS WE LACK
DOCTORS WE LIKE NURSES WE LIKE
ENGINEERS WE LIKE EVERYTHING
AND IF ANYTHING WOULD COVER
NINETEEN HAS REALLY TAUGHT US
IS THAT WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT
THE WAY IN WHICH WE- CREATE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE IN A WAY
THAT'S- BEEN EFFICIENT AND
EFFICIENT FOR ALL CONSTITUENTS
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I AM COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH YOU IN THIS A COMMITTEE TO
ENSURE THAT WE GET THIS BILL
WRITES AND DONE AND IN A WAY
THAT'S ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD
COME EARLY NEXT YEAR IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THANK YOU. AS A
MEMBER I THINK I SPEAK FOR ALL
MY COLLEAGUES WE AGREE WITH YOU
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THESE DISCUSSIONS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD TO CRAFT SOMETHING THAT
CERTAINLY ACHIEVE YOUR GOALS
AND IT PROVIDES OPPORTUNITIES
FOR CALIFORNIANS TO RECEIVE
HIGH QUALITY CARE ACROSS THE
STATE AND IN PARTICULAR IN OUR
UNDERSERVED AREAS SO THANK YOU
FOR THIS. FOR THIS EFFORT THANK
YOU. OUR NEXT ITEM IS FILE ADAM
NUMBER FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHAN. WELCOME SIR YOU HAVE ONE
BILL TO PRESENT TODAY ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE TWENTY TWO PLEASE
PROCEED IN READING. THANK YOU
MR CHAIR IN CENTER FOR A MOMENT
PRESENT AT TWELVE TWENTY TWO
THIS BILL WOULD EXEMPT CANNABIS
BEVERAGES FROM THE OPAQUE
PACKAGING REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY REQUIRED FOR ALL
ANIMALS AND WHAT IS THAT ALL
RIGHTS CAN RESPECT WHICH IS TO
BE PACKAGED IN A GLASS
CONTAINER. THAT IS CLEAR OR ANY
COLOR TO MEET THIS REQUIREMENT
HOWEVER CANNABIS BEVERAGE
PRODUCTS WOULD STILL BE
REQUIRED TO BE PLACED IN
RECEIVABLE TEMPER TEMPER
EVIDENT CHILD RESISTANT PACKAGE
FOR THE PURPOSES OF COMPLIANCE.
CANNABIS BEVERAGES ARE THE
FASTEST GROWING SECTOR OF THE
INDUSTRY BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE
MANUFACTURERS FIND THEMSELVES
HAVING TO ABIDE BY PACKAGING
LANGUAGE THAT WAS SIGNED FOR
EDIBLES SMOKEABLE PRODUCTS AND
FLOWER. THIS IS CONFIDENTIAL
EXPENSES IN PRODUCING CANNABIS
BEVERAGES BY FORCING PRODUCERS
TO SOURCE COMPLYING GLASS
MATERIALS SUCH AS IMPORTING
GLASS BOTTLES FROM THE STATE.
BRENDAN WORK WITH LOCAL
CALIFORNIAN VENDORS FOR HAVING
BOTTLES HAND PAINTED TO MEET
THE OPACITY REQUIREMENTS THIS
WILL PASS REQUIREMENT IS
UNNECESSARILY DRIVING UP THE
COST OF GOODS FOR TERRORIST
PURPOSES PRODUCERS AND DRIVING
BUSINESSES TO FORM PRODUCED
ABOUT OFFERING ANY. BENEFITS
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER. A B.
TWELVE TWO A MAN'S A CURRENT
LAW. OFFERS CAN DISCOVER WE
PASS. CLASSIC AND- IT IS CLEAR
ANY COLOR TO BE TEAM COMPLIANT.
THE SCHOOL HAS NO OPPOSITION
THIS PASS ON CONSENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. TESTIFIED TODAY. THE
CARD POLANSKI REPRESENTING
CANNABIS BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION.
WITH THIS PLEASE. MMHM. HIS
BOOK I PULASKI ON THE LINE.
OKAY THANK. LET'S MOVE TO THE
GALLERY TO HEAR FROM ANY
SUPPORT WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NONE LET'S
CHECK WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
TWENTY TWO I SEE NO SUCH
WITNESSES. LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE TWENTY TWO WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MISTER CHAIR IF I UNDERSTOOD
CORRECTLY YOU WERE EXPECTING A
WITNESS WHO DID NOT RESPOND.
THAT IS CORRECT. SO I GUESS
WE'LL SEE IF THE WITNESSES ON
YOUR IS IN YOUR QUEUE. YES SIR
YEAH WE'RE GONNA START WITH THE
UP LINE. SEVENTEEN ONE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
I'M SORRY I HAD A PRESSTHE
OPTION TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO FOUR FOUR THREE- AND I
APOLOGIZE THAT'S NOT THE BILL
WE'RE ON RIGHT NOW. FIVE I
REALIZE THAT BUT I EXPECTED
DURING THE OPTION FOR WORK FOR
THREE. WELL LET'S WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND TAKE YOUR COMMENT
MEMBER MEMBER IT'S NAME
POSITION ON THE BILL IN YOUR-AFFILIATION THIS IS REGARDING
PARDON ME MISTER CHAIR I I'D
I'D I'D MOVED ON TO THE NEXT
PERSON HERE I APOLOGIZE THAT'S
FINE I THINK I CAN RETRIEVE
THEM AND WE CAN MOVE FORWARD
THAT'S NOT GONNA GO TO LINE.
SIXTY THREE. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF CMG KHALIFA AND APOSS FROM
SUPPORT OF A B. TWELVE TWENTY
TWO THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. AND
AGAIN FOR ANYONE HERE WHO'S
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE MIN
ZERO FOR THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
BUT YOU SURE NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
LET'S NOT FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FOR MANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. FIRST
BEGINNING WITH THE GALLERY ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY TO THIS MEASURE SAYING
NONE LET'S CHECK ROOM ONE
TWELVE. WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE TWENTY TWO.
I SEE NO SUCH WITNESSES LET'S
MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR AGAIN IF YOU.
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO
THIS MEASURE WE WILL PROCEED.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
PRESS. ONE ZERO. TO GO TO LINE
THE SIXTY FOUR. BUY TICKET FOR
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI
MCIVER ANTI CAN EVERYBODY HEAR
ME OKAY PERFECTLY PLEASE
PROCEED SIR. HI I'M I'M SORRY I
WAS HAVING TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES AND HAD- HAD TO
DIAL BACK IN- I'M ACTUALLY HERE
TO- RIGHT THEY'VE BEEN ON
BEHALF OF THE BILL IS THAT OKAY.
PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY SO- MY
NAME'S MAKAI POLANSKI ON BEHALF
OF THE CANNABIS BEVERAGE
ASSOCIATION AND I'M HERE TO-
ADVOCATE THAT WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT OUR SPONSORED MEASURE
AB TWELVE TWENTY TWO RELATING
TO THE FOLLOWING. CANNABIS
BEVERAGE PRODUCTS- THE BILL
EXEMPTS HIM WITH BEVERAGES FROM
THE OPAQUE PACKAGING
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
REQUIRED FOR ALL ANIMALS AND
WOULD INSTEAD AUTHORIZED
CANNABIS BEVERAGES TO BE
PACKAGED IN A GLASS CONTAINER
THAT IS CLEAR. OR ANY OTHER
COLOR TO MEET THIS REQUIREMENT.
WELL TWENTY TWO IS MUCH MEASURE
BECAUSE WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED THE GOVERNOR BROWN
SIGNED- AND MEDICINAL AND ADULT
USE CANNABIS REGULATION AND
SAFETY ACT- OCCURRED. IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE CANNABIS BEVERAGE
SECTOR WITH THE NAVY AND PART
OF THE INDUSTRY. IT WAS SO
SMALL THAT WHEN THE INITIAL
PACKAGING LAWS AND REGULATIONS
WERE FORMULATED THE UNIQUE AND
SPECIFIC NEEDS OF THE CANNABIS
BEVERAGE PACKAGING. FOR
UNFORTUNATELY NOT TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION. TODAY THE
CANNABIS BEVERAGE SECTOR IS NOW
THE FASTEST GROWING SECTOR
WITHIN THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE
MANUFACTURER FIND THEMSELVES
HAVING TO ABIDE BY PACKAGING
LANGUAGE THAT WAS DESIGNED FOR
EDIBLE. MOBILES AND FLOWER
UNFORTUNATELY GIVEN THE UNIQUE
NATURE OF BEVERAGES. THIS HAS
BEEN INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING AND
BECAUSE OF THE COST A TRUE
BARRIER TO ENTRY FOR MANY
CANNABIS BEVERAGE BRANDS AND
MANUFACTURERS. WHAT THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY DOES THAT ALLOW
CANNABIS BEVERAGES TO BE
BOTTLED. IN CLEAR OR ANY OTHER
COLOR CONTAINER. A GOOD THING
WHERE YOU. ARE THAT CANNABIS.
B. AND BOTTLED. BOTTLES THAT
ARE OPAQUE OR AMBER COLORED
AMBER GLASS WALL COMMONLY
AVAILABLE FOR BEER BOTTLES IT'S
NOT READILY AVAILABLE IN THE U.
S. FOR MOST OTHER BOTTLE DESIGN
SHAPES AND SIZES. THIS KIND OF
COMPETITION- EXPENSES IN
PRODUCING CANNABIS BEVERAGES BY
FORCING PRODUCERS TO SOURCE
COMPLAINING ABOUT THE CHERRY
OFFICE SAYS IMPORTING GLASS
BOTTLES FROM EUROPE RATHER THAN
WORKING WITH LOCAL CALIFORNIA
VENDORS OR HAVING BOTTLED HAND
PAINTED TO MEET YOUR PATH YOUR
REQUIREMENT. IT'S ABOUT THE
REQUIREMENT IT IS UNNECESSARILY
DRIVING UP THE COST OF GOODS
FOR CANNABIS BEVERAGE PRODUCERS
AND DRIVING BUSINESS FIFTY
FOREIGN PRODUCERS WITHOUT
OFFERING ANY BENEFIT TO THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS. FOR THE
REASONS STATED ABOVE THE CDA
URGES AND I HOPE FOR A B.
TWELVE TWENTY TWO I FELT CAN
WHEN IT IS CONSIDERED IN THE.
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONALS. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. SURE THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE COULD SIGNAL BUT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU LET'S
NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE
CHAMBER. KELLY KILLINGS ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
CENTERMAN HAS MOVED THE BILL. I
SEE NO OTHER LAKES UP. SEMI
MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THEM SHARE AND MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IPHONE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR MEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS REFERRED THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM FOR A B. TWELVE
TWENTY TWO DO YOU PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ROSS. ROSS I'M
MELINDA'S- HI MELINDA'S I
ARCHULETA. BETH BECKER BACKER
HI DONNA HI DON I EXAMINE HER
TADO JONES. JONES I'D LEAVE
THAT MAN HI MAN I KNEW MAN ALL
RIGHT NEW MAN I TELL A BOGUS
PAN. BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SIR HAVE A
GREAT DAY YOU. TOO THE- NEXT
ITEM IS FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
BUT- IS SIMPLY MEMBER CHOOSE.
SIR WELCOME YOUR ONE BUILDER
PRESENT TODAY ITS ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE FIFTEEN PLEASE PROCEED IN
READING THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
GOOD MORNING SENATORS
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
TODAY OF A. B. NINE FIFTEEN A
BILL THAT WILL HELP OUR STATE
LIVE UP TO ITS PROMISE TO
SUPPORT OUR SMALL DIVERSE
BUSINESSES. AS THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
CALIFORNIA HAS ENORMOUS
PURCHASING POWER. AND WE SHOULD
USE THAT POWER TO HELP SMALL
MICRO BUSINESSES WHO'VE TAKEN
THE LARGEST ECONOMIC HIT DURING
CALL OF IT. AND ARE STILL
STRUGGLING TO RECOVER ON A
DAILY BASIS. IN TWO THOUSAND
SIX GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER
SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT
ESTABLISHED A GOAL FOR ALL
STATE AGENCIES THAT 25% OF ALL
CONTRACTS. SHOULD GO TO
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES.
SINCE THEN AGENCIES HAVE
LARGELY IGNORED THAT EXECUTIVE
ORDER. OF THE TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE STATE AGENCIES
DEPARTMENTS AND COMMISSIONS
ONLY TWELVE HAVE ADOPTED A
SMALL BUSINESS OR DISABLED
VETERANS BUSINESS ENTERPRISE
POLICY. GIVEN THE HIT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES PARTICULARLY DIVERSE
AND MINORITY OWNED SMALL
BUSINESSES AND MICRO BUSINESSES
DURING THIS PANDEMIC WE
SQUANDER REAL OPPORTUNITY TO
HELP THOSE BUSINESSESON THEIR
AMERICAN DREAM. THIS BILL WOULD
CODIFY THAT 25% GO INTO LAW AND
CREATE A FASTTRACK
CERTIFICATION FOR DISADVANTAGED
BUSINESS ENTERPRISES. THIS BILL
ALSO LOOKS AT SMALL BUSINESS
SURVIVAL THROUGH AN EQUITY LENS
BY CREATING AN ECONOMIC EQUITY
FIRST EXPECTATION. THAT
REQUIRES STATE AGENCIES TO
DEVELOP EQUITY PLANS FOR
PROCURING GOODS FROM DVDS. I
NOW LIKE TO TURN THINGS OVER TO
OUR MAIN WITNESS DAVID NELSON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASIAN
PACIFIC CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. MR
NELSON PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND- MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DAVID
NELSON I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC POLICY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE- MISS- A
GREAT THANK YOU TO NUMBER TWO
FOR CARRYING THIS BILL WE'RE
HONORED TO BE CO SPONSORING.
THIS LEGISLATON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HISPANIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AS WELL AS A
CALIFORNIA AFRICAN AMERICAN
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE- THIS BILL
IS REALLY. THE TIME ITS TIME
HAS COME WITH AS A MEMBER CHU
HAS MENTIONED THIS BILL
CODIFIES A 25% SMALL BUSINESS
PROCUREMENT OVER THE CITY
CALIFORNIA. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY CREATES A PATHWAY
OF EDUCATION AND OUTREACH TO
UNDERSERVED BUSINESS
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE. AS OF JUST LAST MONTH-
DATA THAT GOES INTO THE
CALIFORNIA DREAMIN DECKS 41% OF
BUSINESSES IN THE STATE ARE
STILL NOT OPEN. FROM THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC LAST
YEAR. AND WE KNOW THAT
CONTRACTING CAN BE THE
LIFEBLOOD OF SUCCESS FOR ANY
BUSINESS SMALL OR LARGE. AND AT
A CONTRACT WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. COULD BE THE
GATEWAY TO MAKING PAYROLL AND
FEEDING FAMILIES AND POSITIVELY
IMPACT IN THE COMMUNITIES THAT
THESE BUSINESSES OPERATE IN.
EIGHTY NINE ONE FIVE IS
ACTIONABLE IT IS ACCOUNTABLE
AND IT IS ABOUT TIME AND THAT
IS WHY WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. PHONE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR LET'S TURN TO
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WITNESSES
HERE IN THE GALLERY. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. I SEE
NO WITNESSES OTHER THAN
WITNESSES INDIVIDUALS MOVING
AROUND SO LET'S TURN TO
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
AGREES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE ONE FIVE I
SEE NO SUCH WITNESSES LET'S
TURN TO THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS. WRITER IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE WE WILL BEGIN.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME PRESS ONE IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. NOW GO TO
LINE. THIRTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING
THERE AND- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS A LITTLE
MORE OF THE PRESIDENCY OF THE
CALIFORNIA AFRICAN AMERICAN
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. AND TODAY
I'M ALSO REPRESENTING THE BLOOD
OF THE- IN THE CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY BUT AFTER. A WEEK FROM
THE PORT EIGHTY NINE ONE FIVE.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE. LINE.
FIFTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MANNY V. AS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
TRYING TO GET WITH THE FARMERS
CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL VERY
MUCH BEFORE. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. THE LINE. SIXTY SIX.
THE MORNING AFTER CHAIRING
MEMBER WILLIAM MARTIN BURKE ON
BEHALF OF THE BLACK LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE LINE. ONE SEVENTY
TWO. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS RAHUL CAMPILLO
SAN DIEGO CITY COUNCILMEMBER
FOR DISTRICT SEVEN CALLING IN
TO PORT EIGHTY NINE ONE FIVE
AND ALSO TO SAY THAT THE
NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL- OUT LAST
MONTH PASSED A RESOLUTION
UNANIMOUSLY SUPPORTING THE
PASSAGE OF EIGHTY NINE I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOUR LEADERSHIP-
DON'T REMEMBER CHEW AND MR
DAVID NELSON FOR THIS THANKS.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE.
LINES. FOUR NINE SEVENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NEXT PLEASE
GET A MOVE ON THE LINE LINE
TWENTY NINE. HELLO AND MY NAME
IS CONNIE CHAN CALLING ON
BEHALF OF TREASURE FIONA MA
CALLING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. LINE
SEVENTY. HI MY NAME IS HEIDI
PICKMAN I'M WITH CALIFORNIA
PHYSICIAN FOR MICRO ENTERPRISE
OPPORTUNITY FOR CAMEO AWARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE V. NINE
ONE FIVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PLEASE LINE. THE LINE. SIX
EIGHT. YES GOOD MORNING CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS LORI
KAMMER- IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
NINE FIFTEEN I'M REPRESENTING
NOT BOTH CALIFORNIA THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN
BUSINESS OWNERS AND ALSO SMALL
BUSINESS CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. FINE B. SEVENTY.
GOOD MORNING DOCTOR RUBIN GERA
WITH THE LATIN BUSINESS
APPROPRIATION THAT WE ARE IN
FRONT OF THE PORT. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. LINE. FIFTY NINE.
HELLO HIS IS CLOUDY AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE WIND
CALIFORNIA AT WOMEN'S BUSINESS
CENTER NETWORK AND I'M THE
FOUNDER OF THE INVESTING WOMEN
ENTREPRENEURS INITIATIVE-
CALLING IN SUPPORT STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE ONE
FIVE- THAT WOULD REALLY PROVIDE
A FAIR SHARE OF PROCUREMENT
SPENDING FOR WOMEN AND MINORITY
OWNED SMALL BUSINESS. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE LINE. SEVENTY
FIVE. SO GOOD MORNING IS FROM
LEVEL ON THE OF THE BOARD FUND.
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD OF THE
SMALLEST BUSINESS I DO. AND
MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO WAY L.
TWO SIGNAL THEY WILL TO SPEAK
THANK YOU NOT FALL THE SAME AND
HEAR FROM OPPOSITE WITH FOR IN
THE GAL. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SITTING- SUCH
WITNESSES OR THROUGH MOVE TO
ROOM ONE TWO WITNESS WHO WISHED
TESTIFY IN UPPER TO SIMPLY BE
NINE ONE. THIS NO SUCH
WITNESSES. LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECOM SERVER IN THE MINE. FOR
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
WE WILL MOVE FORWARD MODERATOR
SURE THERE IS NO ONE TO SIGNAL
BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU LET'S NOT BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
I SEE SENATOR MAN. WITH THIS
MIKE UP SIR YOU MAY PROCEED I
THANK YOU SIMPLY NUMBER FOR
AUTHORING THIS MEASURE WHICH
WILL HELP PROMOTE EQUITY. AS WE
BUILD BACK OUR ECONOMY I THINK
THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF HAVE
SHOWN US THE IMPORTANCE BUT
ALSO THE FRAGILITY OF SMALL
BUSINESSES AND OUR ECONOMY. WE
HAVE THREE POINT NINE MILLION
SMALL BUSINESSES HERE IN THE
STATE. OF THOSE ONE POINT SIX
MILLION ARE MINORITY OWNED AND
AS WE BEGIN THE LONG PROCESS OF
REBUILDING OUR ECONOMY I THINK
WE HAVE TO. MAKE SURE THAT WE
EMPOWER MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESSES WHICH ARE- SUCH A
CRUCIAL ENGINE FOR. MANY MANY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND-
HISTORICALLY. UNDERSERVED AND
ECONOMICALLY DEPRESSED
COMMUNITIES- WE HAVE TO TRY TO
CREATE A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD I
THINK A. B. NINE FIFTEEN I WILL
PROVIDE THAT CRUCIAL SUPPORT-
THAT REMOVES BARRIERS FOR
DISADVANTAGED ENTITIES AND
PROMOTES ACCOUNTABILITY TO
ENSURE THAT THE STATE IS DOING
ITS BEST TO REACH OUT. TO
MINORITY IN HARD TO REACH
BUSINESSES WHICH OFTEN ARE NOT
AWARE OF THE TYPES OF RESOURCES
THAT. MIGHT HELP THEM SO I'M
PROUD TO BE CO AUTHORED THIS
BILL- THAT COMES AT SUCH A
CRITICAL TIME IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY AND I WANT TO. THANK
THE AUTHOR AGAIN FOR PUTTING
THIS FORM. THANK YOU SIR
MEMBERS ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. SEEING
NONE SOME MEMBERS SHE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I WANT TO THANK
THE GOOD CENTER FROM ORANGE
COUNTY FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
THANK THE COLLISION CHAMBER THE
CALLOUS SPANISH CHAMBER. THE
CALIPHATE MERICAN CHAMBER
DOZENS OF ETHNIC CHAMBERS AND
SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATES NOW
ALL OF US TALK ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF HELPING SMALL
BUSINESSES AND- MOVING FORWARD
THE DIVERSITY OF OUR BUSINESSES
IN OUR STATE BUT WE NEED TO PUT
OUR MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH IS-
IT'S IMPORTANT PARTICULAR
DURING THIS TIME. FOR WHAT I
THINK IT'S BEEN A COMMON SENSE
MAINSTREAM MAIN STREET LEVEL
SOLUTION- AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU MAY HAVE A
MOTION PLEASE. SEARCH A LOT OF
MOVES TO BUILD THE MOTION IS TO
PASS REFERRED THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FINALLY I'M FIVE AB NINE
FIFTEEN DO YOU PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ROSS HI. ROSS I
MELENDEZ. MELINDA'S. I
ARCHULETA- ARCHULETA. BE BY. HI
BECKER I DON. HI DAUGHTER I.
HER TADO. JONES HI. JONES I.
LEIVA. MEN ALL RIGHT MAN HI
NEWMAN. NEWMAN I I'D SHOW A
BOGUS HAN. BILL HAS THE VOTES
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
EPSON MEMBERS THANK YOU SIR
THANK YOU CENTERS. NEXT WERE
MOVED TO- I AM NUMBER EIGHT.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN THIRTY SIX
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA. YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN SENATORS AT TEN THIRTY
SIX WOULD AUTHORIZE THE I. BANK
TO ESTABLISH A MANUFACTURING
DISASTER LOAN PROGRAM AND
MANUFACTURING COMPETITIVE LOAN
PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM CREATED
MECHANISM WHEREBY MANUFACTURERS
CAN SEEK LOAN GUARANTEES TO
EXPAND MANUFACTURING LOGISTICS
CAPACITY OF ESSENTIAL PRODUCTS
DURING THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
A. B. TEN THIRTY SIX HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO
OPPOSITION THUS FAR. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS LAWRENCE
GATE IN THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATIONWHO IS THE SPONSOR
AND- THEY ARE CUTE AND I
BELIEVE TO- THIS WEEK. THANK
YOU SIR- CALLING SIR WITNESSES
I WILL NOTE THAT THIS MEASURE
ENJOYS SUPPORT SUPPORT
RECOMMENDATIONS SO. OKAY YOU
MAY PROCEED. MORNING SHARE
MEMBERS- NORTHGATE INVOLVED
REGULAR JOB REMAINS ACTUALLY
NOT SUCH FROM SMARTPHONE THANK
THE AUTHOR IN HIS OFFICE BUT
OUR WORK ON THIS BILL- THAT
WE'RE PROUD ABOUT THIRTY TEN
THIRTY SIX- THE BILL CREDIT
IMPACT THE MANUFACTURING MAKER
WILL KEEP CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING AT FOREFRONT OF
GLOBAL INNOVATION AND
LEADERSHIP- ON THE CALL AND I
THINK THEY DID MAKE INDIA A
GLOBAL SUPPLY CHAIN DISRUPTION.
TO REALLY EXPOSE ALL PHONE OVER
WE ARE HAVING OUR STEADY SUPPLY
CHAIN WHAT I DO GOOD THAT ARE
OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIAN FACTUAL BY
COMPROMISED FROM CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES THE RESPONDED TO
THE CHALLENGE PRESENTED BY THE
WRITERS INCLUDING ECONOMIC
RECESSION BAR MEANING
OPERATIONAL REVERSING OUR
FACILITY TALENT TO PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED TO CONSUMER GOODS- MAYBE
I CAN GET. YOU KNOW PURSUING
OVER PAST YEAR BUT IF THAT.
CIRCUMSTANCE ADDITION. IS
REALLY CHECK OUR HARD STAYING
LEVEL INVESTMENT BUT IT'S OFTEN
DIFFICULT SMALL AND MEDIUM
MANUFACTURERS WHAT A. B. TEN
THIRTY SIX THE CAR TO MAKE.
WHERE ALL SIZES- THE LONGER.
AND OTHER FUNDING. TO RETOOL
REPORT EXPANDED. AND PRODUCT.
DURING THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
TO MAINTAIN THAT A RELIABLE
SUPPLY. OF THIS BILL
STRENGTHENS THE MANUFACTURING
CAPACITY OF CALIFORNIA BY
PROVIDING THE FRAMEWORK TO
EXPAND FACILITIES AT THE PORT
OF VERY VIBRANT NETWORK I'M AS
A RESULT OFTHIS BILL
CALIFORNIA MAY PRODUCTS WERE
MADE AVAILABLE AND ACCESSIBLE
TO OUR RESIDENTS. AND OTHERS
AROUND THE WORLD IN A IN A
RESPONSE TO- DECLARED BIRDS YOU
CAN RETAIN AND CREATE MORE
QUALITY JOBS THAT ARE
INTRODUCED BILL- WE HAD A TWO
O'CLOCK. LAST YEAR AND
UNFORTUNATELY THE ONSET OF THE-
DEPENDING AGAIN SUPER SESSION-
WE FACE SIGNIFICANT BUDGET
DEFICIT CONSTRAINT THEY
SPENDING THAT KIND OF LED TO
THE DOWNFALL OF MEASURE. WELL I
THINK WE ALL UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF ESSENTIAL GOODS
AND THE ROLE MANUFACTURED
PLAYING THE ROLE OF THE
PRODUCTION LOOK GOODS. AND IT'S
STILL WEREN'T SURE THE CASSETTE
AND BRIGHT FUTURE FOR INDUSTRY
GOING FORWARD- CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO. PARTNER WITH
STATE. UNIVERSALIST GASSER ARGO
THANK YOU THANK YOU LET'S HEAR.
FROM ANY SPORT WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. THE NO SUCH. MOVING TO
ROOM TWELVE. WITNESSES SUPPORT
OF A SIM BIL TWO THIRTY SO.
YOU KNOW SUCH WITH.
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE MY- PLAY
PROMPTING THE END OF. WHEN IT
FINDS OF THIS. WE WILL PURSUE.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK INTO
PLEASE BUTTON AND- GOING TO GO
TO LINE. FORTY FOUR. THANK YOU%
MR MEMBERS DAVID INVOLVED ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES FOUR THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. LITERATURE
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THEY WISH TO STAY. OKAY LET'S
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
FOR MANY OPPOSITION FIRST
BEGINNING WITH OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY. SEE
NO WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION OF THE WITNESSES IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE RIDGE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN THIRTY SIX.
SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR. PLEASE PROMPT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WERE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE AND
WE'LL MOVE FORWARD WITH THEM.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
BUT PARDON ME IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. MR
CHERNOBYL THE SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. FINE LET'S MOVE
LET'S BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBER COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
I SEE NO MAKES UP SOME REMEMBER
GARCIA WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
NOT TO SAY THAT THE SPONSORS AN
EXCELLENT JOB EXPLAIN WHY THIS
BILL IS A PARDON- RESPECT HE
HAS FOR APPLE THANK YOU MAY I
HAVE A MOTION PLEASE SEARCH LET
US SEE YOUR MICO WOULD TAKE
THAT AS A MOTION THE MOTION IS
TO PASS REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. OKAY. FIVE EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHTY TEN THIRTY SIX DO YOU
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ROSS. ROSS HI MELINDA IS HI
MELINDA'S I ARCHULETA- CHILL
OUT IBEATS BACKER NIGHT BECKER
I DON BY DAUGHTER I MEAN. HER
TADO. JONES HIJONES I. LEIVA
MAN MAN I NEWMAN. NEWMAN I A
SHOW ABOUT OPEN. CAN. THEY BOTH
WILL HOLD ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SIR. MOVING
BACK TO FILING OF NUMBER SEVEN
SO MY MEMBER DAILY YOUR ONE
BUILDER PRESENT TODAY ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO TWO FOUR PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS BILL
MODERNIZES OUR STATE DEFINITION
OF A HOUSEHOLD GOODS MOVERS. BY
PROVIDING THE SAME LIMITED
SERVICES EXCLUSION THAT EXIST
CURRENTLY IN FEDERAL LAW FOR
QUALIFIED MOTOR CARRIERS. MOTOR
CARRIERS IN THE SELF MOVING
SERVICE INDUSTRY OFFER
CONSUMERS A SAFE RELIABLE AND
COST EFFECTIVE ALTERNATIVE FOR
MOVING GOODS. THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT THESE
MOTOR CARRIERS. CAN CONTINUE
THEIR REGULAR OPERATIONS
WITHOUT ON RELATED REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS WITH ME TODAY ARE
CHRISTIAN MOTOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION
AND SHANE GUSMAN WITH THE
TEAMSTERS. WHO WILL BE SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT AND WHO ARE CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL. WITNESSES
PLEASE PROCEED. MORE INSURER
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS KRISH
MOTIVE FOR CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN THE HOUSEHOLD MOVERS
ACCEPTED RESPONSIBILITY FOR
OVERSIGHT OF THE MOVING
INDUSTRY FROM THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION TO THE
BEER OF HOUSEHOLD GOODS AND
SERVICES IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
ACT HAS BROUGHT TO LIGHT
INCONSISTENCIES WITH
LONGSTANDING FEDERAL LAW THAT
WE SEEK TO RESOLVE. EIGHTY TWO
TO FOUR UPDATES CALIFORNIA LAW
TO REFLECT ACTION TAKEN BY
CONGRESS IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIVE TO GIVE CONSUMERS A LOWER
COST ALTERNATIVE TO TRADITIONAL
HOUSEHOLD MOVERS BY EXPANDING
CONSUMER CHOICE AND COMPETITION
UNDER FEDERAL LAW TRUCKING
COMPANIES ARE AUTHORIZED TO
PERFORM A LIMITED RANGE OF SELF
MOVING SERVICES PURSUANT TO
THEIR MOTOR CARRIER AUTHORITY.
BY UTILIZING THE HIGHLY
EFFICIENT FREIGHT NETWORKS OF
LESS THAN TRUCKLOAD MOTOR
CARRIERS SELF MOVING PROVIDES
CONSIDER CONSUMERS AS MUCH AS A
25250% SAVINGS OVER TRADITIONAL
MOVERS EIGHTY TWO TO FOUR
SIMPLY ALIGNED STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW WITH RESPECT TO A
NARROW SET OF SELF MOVING
SERVICES AND IN DOING SO
PROVIDES CALIFORNIANS LOWER
COST MOVING OPTIONS AND
SUPPORTS WORKING CLASS TRUCKING
JOBS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK. ABOUT.
NEXT PLEASE. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THE COMMISSION DOES NOT
ON BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS
PRATICA SPONSOR THIS BILL OUR
MEMBERS PERFORM THIS WORK FOR
VERY WELL CAPITALIZED TRUCKING
COMPANIES- WE VIEW THIS AS A
CLARIFICATION OF THE LAW SO
THAT THE COMPANIES WE WORK FOR.
DON'T FACE DEPLETED OF AND OVER
REGULATION. AND HAVE A NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON THE BOTTOM LINE WHICH
OF COURSE HAS A NEGATIVE IMPACT
ON THEIR ABILITY TO PROVIDE
GOOD JOBS FOR US SO WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL. WE ARE GENERALLY NOT
FOR EXEMPTIONS TO REGULATION
BUT IN THIS INSTANCE THESE
COMPANIES ARE REGULATED IN
OTHER WAYS. AND I THINK IT'S
VERY TELLING- ON A CONSUMER
POINT OF VIEW THAT THERE ARE NO
CONSUMER ORGANIZATIONS IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AT INNER DRIVE
A- THANK YOU LET'S TURN TO IN
THE- ANY SUPPORT WITNESSES WHO
WERE IN THE GALLERY ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE IN THE GALLERY.
SAYING NO WITNESSES TO TURN TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE. ANY WITNESSES
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO TWO FOUR. SEEING NO
SUCH WITNESSES LET'S MOVE TO
THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO TWO FOUR WE WILL BEGIN
WITH THEM. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. DOWN TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE MIN
ZERO. MR CHERNOBYL IS SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY
LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS
AND HEAR FROM THE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE
A REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
CALIFORNIA MOVING AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION ON THE LINE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION IF SO
PLEASE PROCEED. H. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE STEVE WHITEY CAMP
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA MOVING
AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION A
HUNDRED AND FOUR YEAR OLD TRADE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING OVER
FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MEMBER
COMPANIES SERVING CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS IN THE REGULATED
MOVING APARTMENTS WE WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON MAYBE THREE TO
FOUR THESE LAST FEW MONTHS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WE REMAIN
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. WE
APPRECIATE THE ASSESSMENT OF
THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT AT THE
ANALYST NOTES WE BELIEVE THE
FEDERAL ARE CLEARLY GIVES
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO
REGULATE THE TRANSPORTATION OF
HOUSEHOLD GOODS WITHIN OUR
BORDERS AND THE FOCUS OF
EXISTING REGULATIONS IS NOT
CENTERED AROUND- LOADS OR
UNLOADS A TRUCK BUT RATHER THE
TRANSPORT. OF HOUSEHOLD GOODS
ALSO AREN'T. BUT ARE MOST AT
RISK. THANKS TO CALIFORNIA
REGULATIONS MOST RECENTLY
ADDRESSED THE NEPHEW NINETEEN
HILL. CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS THAT
UTILIZE MOVING SERVICES ARE
SAFER THAN CONSUMERS AROUND THE
COUNTRY FROM FINANCIAL CRIMES
RELATED TO SCAMMERS THAT
PROLIFERATE NATIONWIDE. THIS
BILL WOULD WEAKEN CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS BY ALLOWING
COMPANIES. ENGAGED IN
TRANSPORTATION OF HOUSEHOLD
GOODS SUBJECT THEMSELVES FROM
STATE OVERSIGHT. THE ARGUMENT
THAT THE SPONSORS PERCEIVE AS
INNOVATION SHOULD ALLOW THEM TO
OPERATE WITHOUT REGULATION THAT
SERVE THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
SO WELL. IS A MORAL HAZARD. THE
JOBS ARGUMENT IS PURE SOPHISTRY
ENACTMENT OF THIS BILL WOULD
ONLY MOVE JOBS FROM THE
REGULATED COMPANIES TO FUND
REGULATED CREATING NO NEW JOBS.
ADDITIONALLY BE HARD FOR ME TO
MOVERS HAVE SERVED AS ESSENTIAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS. BEGINNING A
STATEWIDE SHELTER IN PLACE
ORDERS. DATA PROVIDED BY THE
BUREAU HOUSEHOLD GOODS AND
SERVICES. CLEARLY SHOWS THAT
CONSUMER COMPLAINTS
INVESTIGATION THE BUREAU ARE
OVERWHELMINGLY FOCUSED. ON
UNLICENSED ACTIVITY. WE THAT
**** COMPLAIN. REGARDING
VIOLATION ACTIVE. WILL ONLY CAN
TO GROW THIS BILL SUCCESS. AND
CARRIERS OF HOUSEHOLD GOODS ARE
ALLOWED TO SKIRT STATE LAW.
REQUIREMENTS FINALLY. CURRENT
PROJECT IS NOT COMPLICATED.
EXCELLENT RESOURCE FOR
COMPANIES SEEKING LICENSES AND
THE LICENSE HELD BY THE COMPANY
NOT BY INDIVIDUAL DRIVERS ARE
EMPLOYEES BECAUSE FREIGHT
COMPANIES OFFERING CUSTOMER
SERVICES DO NOT BELIEVE THEY
SHOULD BE LICENSED BY THE STATE
IT'S NOT A JUSTIFIABLE REASON
TO REMOVE THE STATE'S ABILITY.
TO PROTECT CONSUMERS THANK YOU
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR NOTEBOOK. THANK YOU SIR.
LET'S BEGIN WITH- ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NONE. SECURITY
DID THAT TODAY. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. THE
MODERATOR. IF THERE'S ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIR NO WONDER SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU
LET'S BRING THE ART MADE BY I
STAND CORRECTED WE DO HAVE ONE
PERSON I APOLOGIZE PARDON ME.
PARDON ME MR CHERRY JUST
ANOTHER MOMENT PLEASE. WE'RE
GONNA GO TO LINE SEVENTY SIX.
HI I'M STEPHEN FRAZIER RECENT
RETIREE FROM CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY TO THE COACHELLA VALLEY
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HAVING
RECENTLY USED TWO OF THESE
CONTAINER TYPE POT COMPANIES AS
RECENTLY AS THREE WEEKS AGO AND
I AM. HOLD STRONGLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS THE FROG.
THE OVER REACH BUT THESE
COMPANIES- WAS. ABSOLUTELY
OUTRAGEOUS THE. THE FACT THAT
THEY COULD BE EVEN MORE
UNREGULATED. SPEAKS TO THE
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES TO
CONSUMERS LIKE ME IF ANYTHING
THERE SHOULD BE MORE
REGULATIONS I TOTALLY AM AN
OPPOSITION SUPPORTER CALIFORNIA
MOVING AND STORAGE POSITION
I'VE READ THEIR OPPOSITION IN
THE ASSEMBLY PAPERS AND I
SUPPORT THEIR- POSITION IN
OPPOSITION I HAVE NEVER CALLED
TO THE STATE CAPITOL. EITHER
FOR OR AGAINST THE BILL BUT
HAVING BEEN HORROR. AS A
CONSUMER CALIFORNIA CONSUMER BY
THESE COMPANIES. I HAVE BEEN
MOTIVATED FOR THE FIRST TIME TO
CALL IN AND I HOPE MY STATE
REPRESENTATIVE. IN THE
LEGISLATURE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE YOU KNOW AND THE REST OF
THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE MEMBERS
HAVING HEARD NOT FROM A
LOBBYIST NOT FROM AN
ASSOCIATION BUT FROM A CONSUMER
ME. HAVING EXPERIENCED THIS AND
I HAVE IT ALL DOCUMENTED. AND
PUT TOGETHER THAT IT CAN ALL BE
REPRESENTED TOTALLY IN
OPPOSITION I WISH. SURE THERE
IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
LET'S BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE
CHAMBER COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS MEASURE SENATOR
EDMUND. THANK YOU- HI I HAVE
SOME CONCERNS WITH THIS IS THAT.
SO HOW MANY HOW MANY OF THESE
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT THAT WOULD
THEN BE GRANTED THIS EXEMPTION
DO WE KNOW HOW MANY COMPANIES
BECAUSE I MEAN THIS IS A
BUSINESS MODEL CORRECT- THAT
MOVES GOODS RIGHT. SO I JUST
DON'T UNDERSTAND THEN HOW WE'RE
SAYING THEY'RE NOT MOVERS JUST
BECAUSE THEY DON'T DO THE
ACTUAL PACKING BUT THEY DO THE-
THE TRANSPORTATION SO I GUESS I
GUESS I. MEAN HOW MANY ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT IT AND IF WE'RE
DOING AN EXEMPTION TO GET
AROUND. OUR SYSTEM OF
REGULATION- AND ARE. YOU GOING
TO DO IT AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL-
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE IT IS THAT
YOU CAN EASILY. CREATE A
PROLIFERATION OF PEOPLE WHO
JUST MAY NOT ADVERTISE AS OUR
FULL SERVICE MOVERS BUT INDEED
THEY ARE MOVING GOOD SO DO YOU
KNOW ABOUT HOW MANY. COMPANIES
OPERATE UNDER THIS TYPE OF
BUSINESS MODEL WHICH IS. A
DIFFERENT FROM DOING THE
PACKING. WITH THE PERMISSION OF
THE CHAIR. PLEASE SEE I WOULD-
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTED MR
SHIMODA. AND OR MR GUSMAN BUT.
GERMAN EITHER ONE OF YOU WANT
TO RESPOND IF YOU'RE STILL ON
THE LINE. TO RESPOND TO A
CENTER ADMINS QUESTION- THIS
KRISHNA CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION SO WE HAVE- WE WERE
BRINGING THE MEASURE
PREDOMINANTLY ON BEHALF OF
THREE OF OUR MEDICARE MEMBERS
IN WHAT'S CALLED THE LESS THAN
TRUCKLOAD SECTOR TO USE A TRUCK
IN TERM. THESE ARE VERY LARGE
WELL CAPITALIZED CARRIERS WITH
REGIONAL NETWORKS THAT ALLOW
THEM TO PROVIDE THIS SERVICE-
THEY'RE NOT MOVING COMPANIES IN
THE TRADITIONAL SENSE IN THAT
THEY OFFER MULTIPLE LINES OF
SERVICE PREDOMINANTLY IN THE IN
THE- TRADITIONAL FREIGHT
TRUCKING SECTOR. SO AT LEAST
THREE COMPANIES THAT ARE DOING
THIS BUT WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY. AND WE ALSO DON'T KNOW.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THEIR
BUSINESS IS THIS SPECIFICALLY
JUST JUST TO MOVE TO TRANSPORT
GOODS DO WE KNOW THAT. OKAY
JUST TO- FURTHER- CLARIFY I
KNOW WE'VE WE'VE HAD SOME
DISCUSSIONS- WITH COMMITTEE
CONSULTATS ABOUT THE SCOPE. OF
THE MEASURE. AND OR INTENTION-
YOU KNOW THAT WE CAN SPEAK AT
LEAST ON THE CO SPONSOR
STANDPOINT- WAS NOT TO ADDRESS-
COMPANIES WHO ARE LOOKING TO BE
IN THE MOVIE BUSINESS FULL TIME
BUT RATHER. OUR MEMBERSHIP WHO
ARE PREDOMINATELY- FREIGHT
TRUCKING COMPANIES ARE
PROVIDING THIS AS AN ANCILLARY
SERVICE TO. THEIR OVERALL
BUSINESS SO THAT THAT IS A
DISCUSSION THAT WE HAVE. I HAD
HOPED TO HAVE ON ON GOING BASIS.
OKAY I DON'T THINK I HAVE ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS I JUST I
DON'T FEEL LIKE THIS IS IT. IT
FEELS IKE WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
INFORMATION TO BE ABLE TO GROW
UP TO BE GRAND TO GO A WHOLE
BIG EXEMPTION IF WE DON'T KNOW.
THE RAMIFICATIONS OF THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THE NUMBER AND
THEN WHAT WHAT IT DOES TO THE
EXISTING REGULATED INDUSTRY
THAT IS ALREADY ESTABLISHED
THANK. COLLEAGUES ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I WILL I'LL SAY
THIS I- SEARCHABLE. THANK YOU
MR AS A REAL ESTATE BROKER I
HAVE HAD CLIENTS- OVER THE
YEARS WHO VIEWS THIS TYPE OF
SERVICE AND THEIR COMMENTS THAT
I'VE HEARD ABOUT THE TEAMSTERS
THE DRIVERS- THE
PROFESSIONALISM IN DROPPING OFF
THE CONTAINER PICKING HIM UP-
IT'S BEEN FANTASTIC AND THEY'VE
GONE- FROM ONE END TO THE
COUNTY TO THE OTHER. IN SOME
EVEN OUT OF STATE AND THE
CONTAINERS WERE THERE AS AGREED
AND SO I SEE THIS IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT ENTRY
LEVEL OF BUYER AND ALSO PEOPLE-
WHO JUST CAN'T AFFORD THE
NORMAL PROCESS OF HIRING A
LARGE- COMPANY TO PACK THEM UP.
AND AS WE KNOW IN TODAY'S
ECONOMY A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
MOVING FROM POINT A TO POINT B.
AND THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS WILL
ALL PARTICIPATE AND HELP HIM
PACK UP IN THEY COULD FILL UP
THE CONTAINERS AND OF COURSE
THE TEAMSTER DRIVERS- WITH
THEIR EXPERIENCE AND
PROFESSIONALISM. PICK IT UP AND
MOVING ON SO- I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AND I'LL MOVE
IT AT THE PROPER TIME. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR EXCELLENT I
WAS ABOUT TO SAY- SOME OF YOU
KNOW I SORT OF BELIEVE THAT THE
REASON WE REGULATE. ONE
PARTICULAR SECTION OF THE
INDUSTRY OR OCCUPATION THIS
PARTICULAR CASES. WE REGULATE
THOSE WHO MOVE THE HOUSEHOLD
GOODS OF RESIDENTS OF THE
STATE. AND THE PURPOSE I ASSUME
IS TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
HOUSEHOLD GOODS ARE
SAFEGUARDED. BUT DURING THE
PROCESS FROM WITHOUT REGARD TO
WHO ACTUALLY PACKS THE BOXES
WHO ACTUALLY TAKES THE BOXES.
AND PUTS THEM IN THIS CASE IN
THE PODS. SO I BELIEVE I SHARE
THE CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY
SENATOR EGGMAN. ABOUT THIS
MEASURE- AND I COMPLETELY AGREE
WITH MY CUT COME IN THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR ARCHER LETTER WITH
RESPECT TO THE PROFESSIONALISM
OF. THE TEAMSTERS AND OTHERS
WHO WERE INVOLVED IN THIS
PROCESS. BUT I SUPPOSE THE SAME
COMMENTS COULD BE MADE WITH
RESPECT TO THE OTHER ASPECTS OF
THE HOUSEHOLD GOODS MOVING
INDUSTRY AND THEN THE QUESTION
IS WHY REGULATE. A SECTION OF
IT AND THEN. ON NOT ANOTHER
PART OF THE OPERATION. I AM
GOING TO- DEFER TO THE WISHES
F MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
COMMITTEE WITH RESPECT TO THE
MOTION AND THE VOTE- BUT I DO
HAVE THOSE CONCERNS AND I THINK
IF WE MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD IF
THIS BILL MOVES OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE WE SHOULD CONTINUE TO
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS. AS TO
WHAT DIFFERENTIATES. THIS
ASPECT OF THE POT OPERATION AS
OPPOSED TO WHEN YOU JUST HAVE
ONE DROP IN YOUR DRIVEWAY AND
YOU USE IT TO TEMPORARILY STORE
YOUR- HOUSEHOLD GOODS WHILE
YOU'RE REMODELING YOUR HOUSE.
AND THE ASPECT OF THE POT
INDUSTRY THAT REALLY CLOSELY
RESEMBLES THE REST OF THE
MOVING AND TRANSPORT INDUSTRY
IN THIS STATE SO. COLLEGE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS CENTRE ARCHULETA HAS
MOVED. SUBMIT MEMBER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE- IN REGARDING THE
POD IN THE COURSE THERE'S A
COMPANY CALLED POD- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT TYPE OF
BUSINESS IS NOT DEALT WITH. IN
THIS BILL- OTHER TYPES BUT NOT
SPECIFICALLY POD BUSINESS
MODEL- AGAIN I'LL DEFER TO THE-
CO SPONSORS TO CLEAR. OR
CORRECT THAT BUT THAT'S WHAT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS- HAVING SAID
THAT I WILL RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT AND
PLEDGED TO WORK TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH ALL OF YOU- TO
IMPROVE THE BILL IF IT NEEDS TO
BE IMPROVED- WE'VE HAD GOOD
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF- AND OFFERED AN
AMENDMENT BUT THERE'S BEEN NO-
MEETING OF THE MINDS YET. ON
THAT AMENDMENT SO I WOULD
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. OKAY THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER ARCH LOVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS IN RIVER FOR
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. A. B. TWO
TWO FOUR FILE ITEM SEVEN A. B.
TWO TWO FOUR DO YOU PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BROTH. ROSSII
MELINDA'S. ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
IBEATS BACKER. BACKER I DON HI
DON I MEAN THE VOTING HER TADO.
JONES LEAVE US. MAIN NEW MAN
ALL RIGHT NEWMAN I A TO A BOGUS.
CAN. BILL HAS FIVE VOTES WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON.
SIR YOU HAVE- ONE BUILDER
PRESENT TODAY ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
FIVE ONE PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU ARE READY. I WILL NOTE THAT
THIS MEASURE APPEARS TO ENJOY A
SUPPORT SUPPORT. RECOMMENDATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
FIFTY ONE WHICH WOULD CREATE A
PROCESS TO INSURE CEMETERY
CARETAKERS ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THE NEGLECT ABANDONMENT- OF
FINANCIAL MISCONDUCT. FOR
NEARLY TWENTY YEARS FAMILIES IN
THE CITY OF COMPTON AND IN THE
NEIGHBORING COMMUNITIES HAVE TO
IN TATTOO INTO OR THE PAIN. THE
BURDEN OF DEPLORABLE CONDITIONS
AT WOODLAWN MEMORIAL CEMETERY.
I WANT TO UNDERSCORE THAT THIS
IS PERSONAL TO ME BECAUSE I HAD
TO HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS LAID TO
REST AT THE WHEEL AT THE
WOODLAWN MEMORIAL CEMETERY.
SOME OF THE ISSUES IDENTIFIED
WERE- IN DEPLORABLE CONDITIONS
SUCH AS- IT OPERABLE- EMIGRES-
BILL REGRET OF WATER SYSTEMS
USING- WEEDS COVERING THE
ENTIRE- GROUNDS WEEDS GROWING
TO BE FIVE FEET TALL.
TOMBSTONES UNRECOGNIZABLE
UNREADABLE TOMBSTONES THAT ARE
MISSING VEGETATION AS I
INDICATED GROWING UP TO BE FIVE
FEET TALL THE GATES LOCKED THIS
BILL WILL ENSURE. THAT THE NOT
ONE MORE FAMILY HAS TO BEAR THE
PAIN OF FINDING THEIR LOVED
ONES A BANDIT CALIFORNIA'S LAWS
REQUIRE EACH PRIVATELY OWNED
CEMETERIES TO CONTRIBUTE. TO
THE ENDOWMENT CARE FUN TO COVER
CEMETERY MAINTENANCE COSTS
HOWEVER IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN THE CALIFORNIA
CEMETERY FUNERAL ZERO PUBLISHED
A REPORT SHOWING THAT OVER A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN PRIVATELY
OWNED CEMETERIES. IN THIS STATE
WOULD EVENTUALLY FACE
INSOLVENCY DUE TO INSUFFICIENT
ECF INCOME EIGHTY SIX FIFTY ONE
WOULD CREATE- OF WORK WILL
CORRECT THE LOOPHOLES AND
CREATE A PROCESS TO WHOLE
CEMETERY CARETAKERS ACCOUNTABLE
AND PREVENT. THE RISK OF
INSOLVENCY BY GREATLY
INCREASING THE ENDOWMENT
INVESTMENT LEVEL THAT HAS BEEN
LONG OVERDUE THIS. ALSO DIDN'T
DEVELOP. A BACKSTOP FOR
COUNTIES TO ASSUME
RESPONSIBILITY OF A CEMETERY IF
THE COURT FAILS TO APPOINT A
SAY A TEMPORARY CARE TAKER
ULTIMATELY THIS IS ABOUT BEING
ABOUT BRINGING HOPE AND JUSTICE
TO THE FAMILIES IN COMPTON BUT
ALL ACROSS THE STATE F
CALIFORNIA JOINING ME VIRTUALLY
TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONIES THAT I'M GRATEFUL.
IT IS THE CITY ATTORNEY
ATTORNEY DAMON BROWN ALSO THE
FOUNDER OF ONE SECTION AT A
TIME CELESTINA BISHOP WHO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONIES
IN ADDITION WE ALSO HAVE TO
DATE JERRY DESMOND FROM THE
CEMETERY IN MARCH WERE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA WHO'S
HERE TO ADDRESS ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MAY HAVE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU WITNESSES- PLEASE BE
MINDFUL OF OUR TIME CONSTRAINTS
BUT THREE MINUTES FOR TOTAL FOR
THE GROUP SO- MISS BROWN PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU AND GOOD-
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN OF ROCK-
AND ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME AMOS FOR OUT
OF THE CITY ATTORNEY FOR THE
CITY OF COMPTON AND WE ARE
PROUD TO BE A COKE BOTTLE BY
THE LEGISLATION REFORMING
CEMETERY MANAGEMENT AND
OPERATIONS- WOULD LOVE THE
PRIVATELY OWNED CEMETERY IN
COMPTON THE FABLESS IN EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY ONE IN THE FINAL
RESTING HOME FOR MANY.
INCLUDING EIGHTEEN CIVIL WAR
VETERAN AND UNFORTUNATELY OVER
THE COURSE OF MANY YEARS WHAT
MONITORS FALLEN INTO A STATE OF
DISREPAIR AND NEGLECT AND
DESPITE REPEATED WARNINGS FROM
THE CEMETERY AND FUNERAL ZERO
TO REMEDIATE IT MANY VIOLATIONS
OF LAW REGULATING CEMETERY
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE THE
PROPERTY CONTINUES TO LANGUISH
TO THE HORROR OF THEIRS AND THE
COMMUNITY- I AM OVERJOYED I WAS
OVERJOYED WITH THE MEMBER MIKE
IF HE COMMITTED HIS EFFORTS TO
WORKING WITH YOU TO FIND BOTH
SHORT TERM. AND LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS TO THE CHALLENGES
FACED BY WOODLAWN AND OTHER LOT
IN LIFE THE MILITARY IN
CALIFORNIA- ENACTMENT OF THIS
LEGISLATION WILL GREATLY
BENEFIT THE PUBLIC BY IMPOSING
STRICTER STANDARDS GOVERNING
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS OF
PRIVATE MILITARY ENSURING
PUBLIC ACCESS AND NECESSARILY
EXPANDING B. ACCORDING TO THE
BUREAU TO INCREASE
ACCOUNTABILITY THEREBY
DETERRING WOULD BE OFFENDERS
AND SO- THEREFORE I URGE THAT
YOU- GIVEN I'D VOTE- WITH.
MATTER NOW BEFORE YOU THANK.
YOU THANK YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS. A
BISHOP I AM THE FOUNDER OF ONE
AT A NOT. MY NUMBER- BASICALLY
HAVE A BAND IT'S A MATURE IN
OUR CASE THE BLOODLINE I HAVE A
PERSONAL INTEREST WITH WHAT MY
MEMORIAL PARK IN COMPTON MY
MOTHER AND MY THREE SISTERS
SOMEWHERE- BUT I THINK A DEATH
IN JANUARY NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. AND IN TURN AT BROOKLINE
ON JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTH
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN SO I
HAVE BEEN A BIT THAT ARE FULL
WELL OVER FORTY FOUR YEARS.
THROUGHOUT THE LAST TWENTY FIVE
YEARS THE CEMETERY HAD. THREE I
WAS- THROWN BACK. INTO A
PRECIPITATION HEADPHONES WERE
AGAIN- COVERED THAT THERE WERE
HOMELESS AND CAPPING THE WEALTH
THAT THE MILITARY- AT THAT
MOMENT IN TIME OUT TO BE THE
CHANGE THAT WAS NOT WHAT I
NEEDED. AND I FORMULATED A
ORGANIZATION. CALLED ONE
SECTION AT A TIME. WELL THE
LAST MY ORGANISED HAS- WE
HAPPEN. PUT AN EIGHT YEAR
ENGAGEMENT THIS TOWN WE HAVE
COMPLETELY CLEAN THE GROUND-
AND I'M EVERY DAY OPENING THE
GATE AND- PAYING THE BILLS AND
TAKING CARE OF THE PROPERTY.
BUT THAT SHOULDN'T BE MOTHER- I
AM VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL-
THEY PROBABLY WON'T HELP
WOODLAWN WHICH ALLEGED RIGHT
NOW BUT THE PROGRAM'S GOING FOR
SO NO OTHER FAMILY MEMBER OUR
COMMUNITY DOES NOT HAVE TO TAKE
CARE. OF IT YEAH WE TALKED
ABILITY WHEN WE PAY. OUR MONEY
INTO THE DEBT INVESTMENT- IT IS
A HARDWARE HARD- EIGHT ACTOR
SAME. AND AGAIN MY ORGANIZATION
SUPPORTED- FEEL GOOD MIKE FORD
WAIT HOLD THANK YOU KNOW PEOPLE
WILL TRY TO BRING DIGNITY AND
RESPECT BACK HELLO FOR THOSE
WHO ARE DECEIVED BECAUSE WE ALL
WILL BE IN THE SAME SITUATION.
ONE POINT OF TIME IN OUR LIVES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM. NOW
LET'S HEAR FROM ANY SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION ONLY THANK
YOU BY CHURCH MEMBERS JURY DOES
NOT HELP THE CEMETERY AND
MORTUARY ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
SPECIFICALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
ATOMIC YOU'RE FINE INCREASES
INCREASES AS DESCRIBED BY THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT PLEASE YES MISTER CHAIRMAN
OR CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON BEHALF
OF S. C. I. CALIFORNIA FUNERAL
SERVICES ALSO IN SUPPORT OF MR
GIBSON'S BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY AND SUPPORTS SIGNAL
LET'S TURN TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
FIFTY ONE SEEING NONE. LET'S
MOVE THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT AN INDIVIDUAL'S WEIGHT
AND TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FIVE ONE WE
WILL PROCEED. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. SURE NO ONE
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
THANK YOU LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION FIRST
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NONE LET'S
CHECK ROOM ONE TWELVE FOR ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE I SEE NONE. MOVING TO
THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT. INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FIVE ONE WE
WILL MOVE FORWARD WITH THOSE
WITNESSES. IN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE. ZERO PRESS ONE
FRONTIER IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. MISTER CHAIR NO
ONE A SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK FINE LET'S BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE CHAMBER
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. REGARDING
THIS MEASURE CENTER MARCH
LETTER. THANK YOU MR- I'D LIKE
TO CONGRATULATE THE AUTHOR FOR
COMING FORTH AND OF COURSE THE
COMMUNITY OF CONTENT FOR COMING
TOGETHER- AND TAKING PRIDE IN
THEIR COMMUNITY THE STAND UP.
FOR SOMETHING THAT OBVIOUSLY
HAS BEEN THERE FOR YEARS AND
YEARS MY QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR
IS. ISN'T THERE A PROPRIETOR
ISN'TTHERE OWNERSHIP OF THAT
CEMETERY THAT- THEY SHOULD HAVE
MAINTAINED THIS ALONG THE WAY
AND HOW HOW HAS IT ALL FALLING
APART. NOW THAT- WITH THIS BILL
OBVIOUSLY ISN'T IN DIRE NEED OF
CORRECTING THIS BUT HOW HOW DID
THIS HAPPEN AND HOW DO WE
PREVENT THIS FROM HAPPENING
ACROSS THE STATE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR- WE HAVE A
LAW AND THIS BILL SEEKS TO
CLOSE THE LOOPHOLE IN THE LAW-
CEMETERY CARETAKER OWNER CAN
SURRENDER HIS OR HER LICENSE
AND WALK AWAY. AND THIS BILL
SIX FIFTY ONE PREVENTS THAT
FROM HAPPENING IT CREATES NO
ACCOUNTABILITY BUT ALSO
TRANSPARENCY BECAUSE WHEN WE
LAY OUR LOVED ONES TO REST AT-
THEIR FINAL RESTING LOCATION WE
EXPECT THOSE LOVED ONES TO BE
TAKEN CARE OF. IN A CEMETERY
YOU CAN GO VISIT THAT IS THAT
IS- IT'S A QUIET PLACE BUT IT'S
A BEAUTIFUL PLACE AND WOODLAWN
CEMETERY DOESN'T REPRESENT THAT
IN THE PREVIOUS CARETAKER.
COULD NOT AFFORD- THE UPKEEP
AND SURRENDER AND WALKED AWAY
AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CLOSE THIS LOOPHOLE- AS
THE CEMETERY HAS THE CEMETERY
THROUGH THEIR RESEARCH AT THE
SEVEN DAY- CALIFORNIA CEMETERY
AND FUNERAL. BUREAU PUBLISHED
THE REPORT I'M SHOWING THAT
THERE'S OVER A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN PRIVATELY OWNED
CEMETERIES THAT ARE ON THE
BRINK OF INSOLVENCY SO THIS
BILL. WILL CLOSE THAT LOOPHOLE
TO MAKING SURE THE AT ONE THIS
NEVER AGAIN. AND TO PROVIDE A
NEST SUPPORT AND FINANCIAL
SUPPORT. IN WHICH THAT THE
CEMETERIES CAN ABSOLUTELY GET
THE HELP THAT THEY NEED- AND
THEY NEED IT RIGHT NOW SO
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS SO
IMPORTANT AND THIS BILL SEEKS
TO CORRECT THIS FROM HAPPENING.
IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TIME THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS CENTERING THANK YOU
BUT- IF YOU DO AND IS THERE A
MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE IS THEIR
WANT TO CEMETERIES IN PLACE AND
THERE'S NO DAMAGE DO WE KNOW
THE HEALTH OF ALL THE
INDICTMENTS ACROSS THE STATE AT
THIS TIME AND IF YOU'RE GONNA
MAKE SOME ADJUSTMENTS FOR MORE
TO GO IN THERE. BUT I I'M A I'M
A FAN OF CEMETERIES IN HISTORY
AND VISIT THEM VISIT THEM
WHEREVER I GO AND THIS- YOU
KNOW UP IN THE MOUNTAINS THAT
ARE ARE- ARE NOT IN GREAT
REPAIR- BUT I BUT I WONDER YOU
KNOW WHO'S RESPONSIBLE THEN AND
IF THERE IS NO EXISTING AND
DAMAGES THE COUNTY THEN JUST.
PICK UP THE COST FOR
MAINTAINING THAT SURE I WANT TO
DEFER TO MISTER GERRY DESMOND
TO ADDRESS- WHAT PART OF YOUR
QUESTION. THIS DOESN'T. IN THE
GALLERY. THREE GERRY DOESN'T
END WITH THE C. MAX THE
CEMETERY ASSOCIATION FIRST IN
TERMS OF THE OVERSIGHT OF THE
ENDOWMENT CARE FINDS THE SPOT
PRIVATE CEMETERIES THAT ARE
REGULATED OF COURSE- RELIGIOUS
CEMETERIES MUNICIPAL CEMETERIES
ARE NOT REGULATED BUT IN TERMS
OF THE ALMOST TWO HUNDRED
REGULATED CEMETERIES WE REPORT%
ANNUALLY TO THE BUREAU ON OR
INTEL MAKE YOUR FUNDS AND THERE
IS OVERSIGHT OF THE GIRL ON THE
FUNDS. YOU KNOW SECONDARILY AS
DISCUSSED IN THE ANALYSIS THERE
ARE MAINTENANCE STANDARDS
REQUIRED BY STATUTE THAT
ADOPTED BY REGULATION THAT ARE
ALSO OF THE DUE TO INSPECTION
THERE'S I KNOW INSPECTIONS BY
THE BUREAU OF EACH OF THE
PROPERTIES THE WAY THAT THIS
WOULD BE PREVENTED IN THE
FUTURE WE BELIEVE IS A- ADDRESS
BY EIGHTY SIX FIFTY ONE AND ONE
WAY WICH IS. THE OVER THE OVER
A HUNDRED PROPERTIES ARE
REFERRED TO BY A SEVEN MEMBER
GIBSON WE KNOW THAT THERE HAS
BEEN A LONG TIME WAITING FOR
THE ODOMETER FUN MINIMUM
DEPOSITS TO BE INCREASED WE
ESTIMATE THAT WITH THE MEASURE
THE L. DEPOSITS WILL BE
INCREASED ALMOST DOUBLE WHAT
THE NEW KIND OF MECHANISM IN
THE NEW STANDARDS WILL BE IN
PLACE AND THEN SECONDARILY THE
BUREAU IS ADOPTING REGULATIONS
THAT WILL PROVIDE FOR THE
BETTER INVESTMENT. OF THOSE
FUNDS TO ENABLE THEM TO BE- TO
BE MORE SUCCESSFUL IN THE
FUTURE PROVIDE FOR THE
MAINTENANCE OF AN OPENING OF
THE CEMETERIES. YOU KNOW AFTER
THEY RUN OUT OF SPACE IS. TELL
ME OR OR THE OF THE CEMETERIES
HAS THEIR OWN SEPARATE
ENDOWMENT YES THE- THE CENTER
ADMIN JERRY DOESN'T AGAIN P.
EACH CEMETERY- REGULATED
CEMETERY AGAIN. IS REQUIRED TO
MAINTAIN AN ODOMETER FUN FOR
ALL OF THE SEVEN ONE FUN FOR
THE ENTIRE CEMETERY. OKAY AND
THEN AND THEN JUST FINALLY
WE'RE GOING TO INCREASE THE
COST BUT WHO PAYS AT THE-
SENATOR THE SO TO POTENTIALLY
THE COST TO BURY SOMEBODY COULD
GO UP IF THE AMOUNT OF. THE
COST. THE PRICE OF THAT REAL
ESTATE PROPERTY GOES UP IS THAT
CORRECT HE PUT UP A POTENTIALLY
OF LIKE MANY OTHER INDUSTRIES
IT'S QUITE COMPETITIVE AND IT'S
A BUSINESS DECISION OF EACH
CEMETERY BUT KNOWING THAT IN
SOME CASES IN COMPETITIVE AREAS
THE COST MAY BE. UPDATE JUST
THE PRICE MAY BE ADJUSTED
UPWARD THAT'S WHY THE
LEGISLATION THANKS TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON WILL
INCREASE OVER THREE YEARS SO
THAT IT'S NOT A SHOCK IN THOSE
CASES WHERE IT WILL BE THE
CONSUMER THE PACE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SEEING NO OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
NO MIKE'S UP. SIMPLY MEMBER
GIBSON WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS FOR THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION AGAIN THIS IS AN
ATTEMPT TO MAKING SURE THAT-
LOVED ONES ARE LAID TO REST IN
A PLACE THAT CAN CONTINUE TO
CARE FOR THEM- FOR GENERATIONS
TO COME AND SO WE DON'T WANT TO
HAVE A CEMETERY THAT WE LATER
ON MOTHER OR FATHER OR LOVED
ONES- TO REST THAT IS IN
DEPLORABLE CONDITIONS. THAT IS
EMBARRASSING TO THE FAMILY AND
ALSO DISRESPECTFUL TO OUR LOVED
ONES ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN
I VOTE. FOR MOTION. SALOON MADE
THE MOTION MOTION EFFECTS
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. VIOLATED NINE EIGHTY SIX
FIFTY ONE DO YOU PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PROCESS- ROCK HI
MELINDA'S SIDE MELINDA'S I
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA IBEATS
BECKER ALL RIGHT BACKER I DON.
EIGHT MIN HI ADNAN I HER TADO.
JONES LLEVA MAN ARE MEN NINE
NEW MEN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN I SHOW
A VOGUE. CAN I CAN I BILL HAS
THE VOTES WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. SOME
REMEMBER GONZALEZ YOU HAVE ONE
BUILT TO PRESENT TODAY ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO EIGHT SIX PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN SENATORS I'D
LIKE TO START OFF BY ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS LISTED THE NOW
SYSTEM I WANT TO THANK YOU AND
YOUR STAFF- FOR YOUR COMPLETE
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS BILL. EIGHTY
TWO EIGHTY SIX AIMS TO PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY TO BOTH RESTAURANT%
OWNERS AND CUSTOMERS AND FOOD
DELIVERY TRANSACTIONS ENSURING
THEY UNDERSTAND THE TRUE COST
OF SERVICE AND WHO IS PAYING
FOR THEM. IN RECENT YEARS FOR
DELIVERY COMPANIES HAVE
AGGRESSIVELY ENTERED THE FOOD
SERVICE SPACE MAKING PROMISES
THAT THEY WILL GROW RESTAURANT-REVENUES AND EVEN OFFERING
LIMITED TIME DISCOUNTS TO GET
RESTAURANTS TO JOIN. IN
EXCHANGE FOR LISTING RESTAURANT
ON THEIR SERVICE AND PROVIDING
DELIVERY SERVICE RESTAURANTS
PAY DELIVERY COMPANIES A
COMMISSION ON THEIR SALES THESE
COMMISSIONS AND FEES VERY
RESTAURANT RESTAURANT WITH
COMMISSION RATES FREQUENTLY
REACHING AND EXCEEDING 30% OF
THE PURCHASE PRICE. CONSUMERS
ALSO PAY A VARIETY OF FEES FROM
SPECIFIC LISTED DELIVERY FEES
TO HIDDEN COSTS AN INFLATED
MENU PRICES TRANSPARENCY THE
COST OF SERVICE WOULD HELP
EMPOWER ALL PARTIES TO MAKE AN
INFORMED DECISION ABOUT WHICH
ENTITIES TO PARTNER WITH AND%
PURCHASE FROM. EIGHTY TO EIGHTY
SIX IS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED.
WOULD PROVIDE THE NOTICE TO
CONSUMERS. L. FEES RESTAURANT
MAY PAY TO THIRD PARTY DELIVERY
COMPANIES. FURTHERMORE THE FOOD
FACILITY WOULD RECEIVE A
COMPLETE PICTURE THE FEES
CONSUMERS PAID TO THE DELIVERY
COMPANY. THIS BILL WOULD ALSO
ENSURE CONSUMERS ARE GETTING
CHARGED FOR THE PRICE SET BY
THE FOOD FACILITY AND NOT%
CHANGE BY AN HOUR. LAST THIS
BILL WILL ENSURE TIPS AND
GRATUITIES ARE PAID DIRECTLY TO
THE DELIVERY DRIVER. OR FOR
PICK UP ORDERS TO THE FOOD
FACILITY I HAVE A- WITNESS ON
THE LINE DAVID SIGN THE OWNER
MAKES A PIZZA COMPANY IN SANTA
BARBARA. SIR PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAN FINISHES
MY NAME IS STEVEN FRAYNE THING
AND I'M THE OWNER OF THE
COMPANY IN SANTA BARBARA
CALIFORNIA. MAYBE A BRIEF
BACKGROUND ON MYSELF I CAME
FROM SO THAT YOU CAN EIGHTY SIX
AND OPENED MY PERSPECTIVE
PIZZERIA AND SUBSEQUENT STORES
YOU CAN STOP AT THE KING AND HE
DIDN'T PLAY BUT THEN HAD GREAT
SUCCESS. WE ARE DOING A HOME
DELIVERY TIME SO TWO THOUSAND
AND NINETEEN WHEN THE SERVICE
INDUSTRY HAD A DECLINE. WE
USED. TO EASILY BE A TELEPHONE
DELIVERY COSTS BUT THAT WASN'T
THE CASE. PUBLISHED DESTROYING
US WITH FROSTING HE DIDN'T BEAT
UNDER THE GUISE OF HELPING
BUSINESSES MAKING IT IMPOSSIBLE
TO MAKE A PROFIT. LET ALONE PAY
STAFF WAGES AND COST OF THOSE.
PEOPLE I MEAN THE TRUTH JEEP
ANALYSIS OF THE HOLOCAUST AND
EXPOSE THEM ON MY STORE
INSTAGRAM PAGE AND IT WENT
VIRAL. I'M HERE TO JUSTIFY THE
STRONG SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO EIGHTY SIX AND I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE ORDER BOTH OF WORK
AND ON THE MACHINE. AND THE
CONTINUED EFFORTS TO ENSURE
EFFECTIVE AT THE MOMENT AND
WHAT IS. THE STRONGEST
PROTECTION IN PLACE FOR. THE
THIRD PARTY COMPANY. EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY SIX SIMPLY
PROVIDE A PRICE CHANGE FAILING.
TO BOTH RESPOND ONLY. TO SHOW
THAT WE HAVE A LITTLE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE FULL COST
OF THE SERVICES PROVIDED. BY
THIRD PARTY FOOD DELIVERY
COMPANY. CHANGE HERE IN. ON
SCREEN SHOT BY THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY COMPANY TO CUT LEAD.
AND ONLY. IF THE PHONE IS. AGE
DELIVERY COMPANY TECH INCLUDING
DESIGN PRACTICE THAT UPS THE
STAY THREE OF IMPACT IT'S A-
PROFITS IN WORKERS OKAY.
TRANSPARENCIES TO IMPOSE
BUSINESS- OWNERS AND THE FULL
SCOPE OF THE KEYS SIX PAY AND
GET BY MAKING CLEAR DECISIONS
ABOUT THAT YEAH THAT THE POLICY
DELIVERY COMPANY ACTUALLY
PROVIDE H. SO YOU WHAT DID YOU
YOU KNOW THE- FOR. A SERVICE
EIGHT OR ZERO AND CODE AFTER
YOU FOR SO THEY CAN MAKE
CHOICES ABOUT WHERE TO AND HOW
TO. THE SERVICE. WITHIN
UNDERSTANDING OF ALL THE
SERVICES SECTOR LOOK COMMUNITY.
BE TRANSPARENT ABOUT THE MANY.
YOU NINETY COURSES J. WE. ALL
THE- HOLD THIRD PARTY DELIVERY
COMPANY THE CALL. TO MANY
STATES IN LIFE THE SET. IN FACT.
STAND RECENTLY PROBLEM.
EXISTING PERCENT. CHICAGO DC
AND SHOULD BE FROM. TO BOTH
COMPANIES THAT COMPLY.
CALIFORNIA'S AND CAN LEAD THE
WAY FOR. FORTY THREE I RESPECT
ON YOU FOR YOUR TOLD ON EIGHTY
TWO EIGHTY SIX TWENTY PLUS THE
LOW SO THAT COULD PUT YOU MAN
CRISIS AS WE SPEAK DEBATE
RACIAL CLEANSING AND GENOCIDE
GOING TO GAMES THE MINORITIES
OF THIS COUNTRY AS WELL AS
POSSIBLY AND IT CAN BE COOL.
THIS IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW AS
WE. SHOW AND WE NEED THE WORLD.
ATTENTION AND HOW. WE THANK YOU
SO FOR YOUR HELP ON THEIR
EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY THREE. AND
GREAT EIGHT EIGHT FIVE FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY LET'S TURN TO
SUPPORT WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. I SEE NO WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY STANDING IN SUPPORT
OF THEIR ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
EIGHT SIX. SITTING NOW LET'S
MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT. ANY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHT SIX
WE WILL BEGIN. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO.
AGAIN FOR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
PRESS ONE MIN ZERO. TO GO TO
LINE SEVENTY EIGHT. AND PARDON
ME JUST A MOMENT. FIVE SEVENTY
EIGHT THE ONE SO BUT- GOOD
MORNING KAREN BACK MEETING
MEMBERS AT THIS DADDY GREAT
WALLET YET HE W. I FANCIED
COUNCIL AND SEIU CALIFORNIA AND
DRUG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. LINE. NINETY
ONE. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
RECAP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. LINE. EIGHTY
EIGHT. MR CHAN NUMBERS CAITLYN
BAKER FOR THE LAST TEN TO THE
COUNTY FEDERATION OF LABOR AND
UNITE HERE LOCAL ELEVEN IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
LINE NINETY SEVEN. MORNING MR
MEMBERS CHRIS RESPONSE AS PART
OF TO LECTURES AND ALONG PARTY
LINES ON SUPPORTERS MEASURE
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. LINE.
NINETY WE'RE NOT IN THIS ALONE
SOLD FOOD ON CRENSHAW WE OPPOSE
THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. SURE THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE WOULD SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK. LET'S NOT FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FOR MANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES MY
UNDERSTANDING IS A LITTLE ROAD
SHOW IS ON THE LINE. AND CLARK
DAVIS IF SO PLEASE PROCEED IN
ORDER. HI **** ROGER CAN YOU
HEAR ME. PLEASE PROCEED. HI MY
NAME IS BILLY ROACH ON THE
FIELD THE LATINO RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION I'M DELIGHTED
SUPPORTS AND PROMOTES
RESTAURATEUR SMALL BUSINESSES
IN THE ENTIRE LATINO RESTAURANT
COMMUNITY ON BEHALF OF OUR
EIGHT HUNDRED NUMBER THAT WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR CONTINUED
OPPOSITION SHOULD SIMPLY GO TO
EIGHTY SIX ADULT ADS IT IS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN WELL WE
SUPPORT THE REMOVAL OF THE
CURRENT ACCOUNT PROVISION OF
THE BILL WHAT CONCERNS FOR THE
BADLY NEEDED PROVISION BOOK
CLUB FIFTY FIFTH AT A
COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE.
PUBLIC WITHIN A RESTAURANT HAD
TO CLOSE THEIR DOORS DURING THE
DURING UNDER THE PRESSURE OF
THE INDOOR DINING WILL
PROTECTION THAN OTHER TYPES OF
PROTECTION BECAUSE YOU'RE MANY
OF OUR MEMBERS DIDN'T RETURN TO
DELIBERATE ON THE THIRTY FIFTH
GOING OFTEN FOR THE FIRST TIME
AND INDEED WERE ABLE TO KEEP
THE BUSINESS ALIVE DURING THE
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TIMES
BECAUSE OF THE PLATFORM-
DELIVERY PLATFORM TO GIVE OUR
MEMBERS MORE FLEXIBILITY AND
CHOICE AND LET US DECIDE WHAT
SERVICES WORK BEST FOR A
BUSINESS THAT. THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PROVISION IN THE BILL WHICH
WOULD REQUIRE DELIVERY
COMPANIES TO PUBLICLY DISCLOSE
THE CUSTOMER'S EMISSION AND
INFORMATION PAID BY US ON FOR
DELIVERY SERVICES BROUGHT.
EVERYTHING BUT THEY'RE CHOOSING.
WE APPRECIATE MAN BECAUSE BY
THE COMMITTEE AND WE ARE
REVIEWING THEM AND FEEL LIKE
STILL. IS IN A MUCH BETTER
PLACE THAN PREVIOUSLY THOUGHT
WE NEED TO DISCUSS THIS WITH
OUR EIGHT HUNDRED BUT NUMBERS.
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MA'AM.
BUT DAVIS. THE NEW CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CLARK
DAVIS AND I'M ON THE INDUSTRY
RELATIONS TEAM AT CHILI'S AND
MAGGIANO'S RESTAURANTS THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY. WE APPRECIATE
THE OFFER WILL MOVE INTO
PERMANENT CAPTAIN BILL WE DO
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
COMMISSION DISCLOSURE
PROVISIONS AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED
EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY SIX WOULD
REQUIRE THIRD PARTY DELIVERY
PLATFORMS TO DISCLOSE WHAT UR
RESTAURANTS PAY PLATFORMS IN
COMMISSIONS TO OUR RESTAURANT
CUSTOMERS TO TAKE PLACE THROUGH
THOSE PLATFORMS RECORD BREAKER
DATA PARENT COMPANY COULD BE
USED TO CLASSROOMS IS IT A PAID
A COMMISSION TO PLATFORMS
BECAUSE WE NEGOTIATE PEACE
RAISED DIRECTLY WITH THE
PLATFORMS WHICH COULD BE EASILY.
PAY A VOLUNTARY AND
CONFIDENTIAL. RIGHT BUSINESS TO
CONTRACTS MAYBE. GERMAN PRIVATE
BETWEEN PARTIES WHO VOLUNTARILY
NEGOTIATE AND AGREE TO THESE
CONTRACTORS. ADDITIONALLY THIS
INFORMATION IS HIGHLY
COMPETITIVE BETWEEN RESTAURANTS
THE PANDEMIC HAVE BEEN
DIFFICULT ENOUGH ON THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY AND WE
CANNOT RISK IMPLEMENTING THIS
BILL AFTER THE TUMULTUOUS YEAR
RESTAURANTS HAVE. A BETTER
SOLUTION WOULD BE TO REQUIRE
PLATFORMS TO DISCLOSE TO
CUSTOMERS THAT RESTAURANTS LIKE
CHILI'S AND MAGGIANO'S DO IN
FACT PAY A COMMISSION AS PART
OF THE TRANSACTION. WITHOUT
REQUIRING THE DISCLOSURE OF THE
ACTUAL WORK. THAT BEING SAID I
APPRECIATE THE REASON THAN
THAT- ADDITION OF AMENDMENTS
ALLOWING US TO. OPT OUT OF
DISCLOSURE AND IT'LL BE ALL THE
LOOKS UP TO THEM. PLEASE READ
ZERO CLOSE. TO EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY SIX WITHOUT AMENDMENTS
THANKS FOR TALKING TO. THANK
YOU. BERNIE WHAT THIS IN THE
GAL AND UP. TO MEASURE I SEE
ONE SIR PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. YOUR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA GROCERS
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION. THE
COMMITTEE FOR INCLUDING OUR
SPECIFIC CONCERNS IN THE
ANALYSIS THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR LET'S TURN TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHT SIX.
I SEE NO SUCH WITNESSES LET'S
MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROP WITNESSES. WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHT SIX WE
WILL MOVE FORWARD WITH THOSE
WITNESSES. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
NINE ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. WE'LL GO
TO LINE EIGHTY NINE. GOOD
MORNING JEFF EVEN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE BLACK WESTERN
COALITION AND I CAN'T DO IT.
EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. LINE. EIGHTY SIX.
HI MY NAME IS KAYLA CARDING I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE VALLEY
INDUSTRY AND COMMERCE
ASSOCIATION AND MY GUESS
STRONGLY OPPOSES EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. NINE NINETY TWO. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JUST THE
HIERARCHICAL COMBAT LEADERSHIP
GROUP AND WE HAVE BEEN OPPOSE
CONDITION AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
LINE. TWENTY EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING GIVEN TO ME TO ME AND
THE TECHNICIAN WERE STILL
REVIEWING THE MILLIONS I THINK
THOSE IN A MUCH BETTER PLACE
BUT WE STILL HAVE A POST
POSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. LINE NINETY FIVE.
HI DON OFTEN ON BEHALF OF
INTERNET ASSOCIATION ARE
REPAIRING THE AMENDMENTS AND
OUR POSITION AND ONE OF THEM-
BUT OPPOSED TO DELIBERATE THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. LINE.
EIGHTY FIVE. HI THIS IS LOUISE
OR DEAL WITH THE INLAND EMPIRE
ECONOMIC PARTNERSHIP IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. LINE.
NINETY BY NINETY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HERNANDEZ ELEVEN A
CRENSHAW FOR FOOD WE ARE PULLED
AP TWO EIGHT SIX. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. LINE. SIXTY SEVEN.
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE TEACHER THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU LET'S BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
SENATOR MAN FOLLOWED BY.
SENATOR EDMUND. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR- SO I DID HAVE A QUESTION
I GENERALLY THINK THE
TRANSPARENCY BILLS OF THIS KIND
ARE ARE GOOD AND- YOU KNOW
SUPPORT THE GOALS OF THIS BILL-
I DID WONDER WHETHER THE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESSING THE
CONCERNS OF THE GROCERS I. YOU
KNOW HEARD FROM THE GROCERS
EARLIER THIS WEEK ABOUT SOME OF
THEIR CONCERNS AROUND. THE
PRICING BUT- AS I AS I READ THE
AMENDMENTS TODAY THEY SEEM TO.
ADDRESS ANY CONCERNS AROUND
GROCERS HAVING SALES AND THOSE
PRICES. BEING REFLECTED OR NOT
REFLECTED IN THE FOOD DELIVERY
PLATFORM WEBSITE SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS BOOKED TO. MISTER
BROWN AND ALSO TO THE AUTHOR TO
JUST UNDERSTAND BETTER HI
WHETHER THESE AMENDMENTS- DO
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS OR NOT
AND ALSO WHETHER- THE AUTHOR
BELIEVES THEY DO AND IF THEY
DON'T IF SHE'S WILLING TO
CONSIDER FUTURE AMENDMENTS TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS.
OUT LAID OUT BY THE GROCERS. I
WILL SAY I THINK- I THINK THE
CHAIR REALLY PROVIDE ME WITH A
VERY CLEAR AMENDMENT SO THAT
IT'S CLEAR THAT IT IS THE FOOD
FACILITY SETTING WHATEVER FEET
WHATEVER COST. WHATEVER SPECIAL
THAT THEY WON IT'S JUST CAN'T
BE MANIPULATED OR CHANGED BY
THE APP. IF IF GROCERS AREN'T
HAPPY WITH WITH- WHAT I THOUGHT
WAS VERY GRACEFUL SOLUTION
WE'RE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO.
CLARIFY I DON'T KNOW I THOUGHT
IT WAS PRETTY CLEAR DEFINITELY
CLEAR THAT WE HAD IT BEFORESO
I'M HOPEFUL THAT- IF THERE'S
STILL WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE OUR OUR- OUR GOAL. IS
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE A LOT OF
CASES THAT CAME TO US WHERE
WHERE THE APPLE IS. CHARGING
THE MENU OR SALE PRICE AND
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO TRY TO
AVOID- AND BEFORE- I TURNED TO.
A MISTER BROWN FROM THE CHAIRS
STANDPOINT SINCE WE WERE VERY
ACTIVELY INVOLVED. WITH THE
GRACIOUS CONSENT OF THE AUTHOR
I WILL NOTE. THE INTENT IS. TO
MAKE THE UNLAWFUL LAWFUL
DECISION POINT. WHAT IS POSTED
BY THE FOOD FACILITY. ON THE
MENU WHEN THE FOOD PLATFORMS.
BRO CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA GROCERS
ASSOCIATION A WE'RE STILL
REVIEWING THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS AS WE JUST SAW THEM
LATE LAST EVENING TO SEE HOW
THEY WOULD IMPACT US BUT WE
STILL DON'T SEE THAT THE SCOPE
OF THE BILL NATURALLY FITS
GROCERS THIS IS A BILL DEALING
WITH FOOD DELIVERY OF FOOD AND
BEVERAGES AND IS FOCUSED ON THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY OUR
AGREEMENTS WITH OUR THIRD PARTY
FOOD DELIVERY PROVIDERS- ARE
MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE- WE ALREADY
DISCLOSED WHEN PRICES MAY BE
DIFFERENT ON THE APP. AND
FRANKLY JUST DON'T SEE HOW THE
INTENT OF THE BILL FIX OUR
BUSINESS MODEL SO AGAIN WE WILL
REVIEW THE AMENDMENTS BUT AT
THIS POINT WE JUST DON'T SEE
HOW THIS BILL FIX OUR BUSINESS
MODEL OUR AGREEMENTS AND THINK
THAT WE SHOULD BE WRITTEN OUT
OF THIS SPECIFIC SECTION. THE
MANAGER BY SENTIMENT I'LL JUST
SAY THAT GIVEN THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO ACCEPT THESE
AMENDMENTS- THE WAY THAT I READ
THE AMENDMENTS IN THE BILL- I
WILL SUPPORT THIS BILL TO MOVE
IT OUT OF COMMITTEE BECAUSE- IT
DOESN'T CLEAR THE AUTHORS-
TRYING TO MOVE THIS IN A WAY
THAT ADDRESSES THE GROCERS
CONCERNS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND I WOULD MOVE TO BUILD A
PROPER TIME THANK YOU SIR-
CENTER ADMIN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR- THANKS TO
THE AUTHOR. OF THIS IS THAT. I
GUESS I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
WHO THIS HELPS. THIS IS
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION SO ARE WE
ARE WE TRYING TO. INITIALLY
APPELLEE PROTECTING THE
BUSINESS ARE WE PROTECTING THE
CONSUMER I GUESS IS MY QUESTION
BECAUSE- LIKE LIKE SO AS A AS A
CONSUMER I KNOW THAT IT IS
BETTER FOR THE RESTAURANT IF
I'M AN ORDER FOOD THAT I GO
THERE AND EAT. IF NOT I CAN GO
THERE AND PICK IT UP. THERE ARE
SOMETIMES THOUGH WHEN I DON'T.
WHEN I'M FEELING A LITTLE LAZY
I DON'T WANT TO GO OUT AND THEN
I KNOW I'M GOING TO FEEL A BIT
MORE AND BUT IT IS A BUSINESS
MODEL. SO AND I DON'T KNOW THAT
I NEED TO KNOW. ALL OF THAT
BECAUSE WHEN I WHEN I DO IT ON
MY APP AND HAVE THEM GO LOOKING
AT OUR APP ONLY WHEN WE USE
THESE AND YOU CAN SEE WHAT IT'S
GOING TO COST YOU SEE THE
TOTALLY SEE EVERYTHING. WHY DO
I NEED SOMETHING ELSE AT THE
END T TELL ME. WHAT I THINK
WHAT I ALREADY KNOW AND I GUESS
AND I GUESS. WHO WHO CARES WHO
WHO'S BEEN PROTECTED BY THIS.
ACT AND IT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
I ACTUALLY THINK EVERYBODY'S
BEING PROTECTED BY THIS AND
THAT WAS A SET AT THE BILL CAME
TO US THROUGH RESTAURANTS FIRST
WHICH IS INTERESTING- BECAUSE
OF. OF A LACK OF TRANSPARENCY-
WITH THE APPS. WHAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE HAD GOOD EXPERIENCES IN
YOU MIGHT. WHAT CAME UP ON
YOUR- ON YOUR PHONE MAY HAVE
BEEN WHAT YOU WERE ACTUALLY
CHARGE THERE ARE OTHER PEOPLE
WHO HAVE COME AND SAID. WAIT I
ORDERED THIS AND THEN ALL OF A
SUDDEN I HAD ADDITIONAL FEES
CHARGED. AND I DON'T KNOW WHERE
THIS CAME FROM I DON'T KNOW
THAT WHY THERE'S A DISPARITY- I
DON'T KNOW WHY. SO WE CAN GO
THROUGH ALL IT'S ALL ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY IT'S LETTING
CONSUMERS KNOW. WHAT THEY'RE
BEING CHARGED AND WHY THEY'RE
BEING CHARGED THAT. TO LET
CONSUMERS KNOW THAT THE PRICE
THEY'RE PAYING FOR A MENU ITEM.
IS SET BY THE RESTAURANT AT THE
OP DIDN'T. PAD ONTO THAT
BECAUSE WE HAVE WE'VE- WE'VE
FOUND ALL OF THESE CASES RIGHT.
THEY THAT THEY KNOW- IT'S- FOR
THE RESTAURANT- AND TERE ARE A
LOT OF RESTAURANTS COMING OUT.
COBIT WHO ARE LIKE. HEY I YES
WE HAVE TO RELY ON THIS TO KEEP
OUR DOORS OPEN BUT- PEOPLE NEED
TO KNOW HOW MUCH. OR IT'S NOW
THE RESTAURANT'S CHOICE WHETHER
THEY WANT TO DISCLOSE THE
AMOUNT BUT THAT THEY- ARE. ALSO
PAYING A FEE A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T. REALIZE I THINK. HI WHAT
IS GOING ON HERE. AND IT'S ALSO
THE TIPS AND GRATUITIES TO MAKE
SURE. THAT THE DRIVER- YOU
KNOW. GETS THOSE ACTUAL TIPS
AND GRATUITIES AND THAT THE
RESTAURANT IF IT'S A DELIVERY
ORDER. ARE YOU AT THE PICKUP
ORDER THAT THE RESTAURANT. GETS
IT IN NOT THE APP COMPANY. SO
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO. ENSURE
THAT. WHAT YOU WOULD THINK
NORMALLY. IS HAPPENING BECAUSE
THERE ARE NO RULES RIGHT NOW
AROUND IT. AND THAT YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE PAYING
FOR. THAT IT'S CLEAR IT'S UP
FRONT AND YOU HAVE THAT
INFORMATION. RIGHT BUT DID YOU
SEEMS TO BE AN AN INHERENT
ASSUMPTIONS THAT WE SHOULDN'T
BE CHARGED LIKE BECAUSE
SOMEBODY'S GONNA PAY RIGHT SOME
IS GOING TO PAY THAT FOR TO GO
PICK IT UP AND INSURE I MEAN
SURE RIGHT. SO I ASSUME THAT
I'M GOING TO BE CHARGED WHEN I
WHEN I HAVE SOMEBODY BRING MY
FOOD TO MY DOOR. ABSOLUTELY AND
I ACTUALLY THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT- BECAUSE THERE ARE
ALL THESE YOU KNOW THEY THEY
THEY COME UP WITH THE SALES
LIKE YOU'RE GOING TO GET THIS
WE HAVE FREE DELIVERY DELIVERY
IS NOT FREE IT IS IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND THAT IF
SOMEBODY'S JOB THAT IS AT YOU
KNOW. WHAT HAPPENS SO WHEN IT'S
FREE FOR US AS A CONSUMER IT'S
BEING CHARGED TO THE RESTAURANT
AND MAYBE WE THINK THAT'S
OBVIOUS RIGHT BUT THERE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE THINKING
THROUGH ALL OF THESE AND WHAT
WE WANT IS PEOPLE TO HAVE THAT
INFORMATION. MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION I FULLY ANTICIPATE
THAT THIS WILL CONTINUE THIS
IS- THIS KIND OF TRANSPARENCY
IS IN PLACE IN DIFFERENT CITIES
THIS IS JUST ALLOWING EVERYBODY
TO KNOW THE TRUTH ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON YES DELIVERIES COST
THAT'S OKAY THAT'S- THE
CONVENIENCE AND HOPEFULLY
PEOPLE REALIZE. IF I GET MY
LITTLE CODE AND I GET FREE
DELIVERY SOMEBODY IS STILL
PAYING THAT DELIVERY IT'S NOT
YOU KNOW AND WHO IS PAYING
INTEREST SO THAT THEY HAVE THAT
INFORMATION. OKAY SO. SO
BASICALLY THE BILL IS TO LET
PEOPLE KNOW. THAT THEY ARE
PAYING FOR DELIVERY. WELL WHAT
SOME PEOPLE DIDN'T REALIZE THEY
THINK THEY'RE PAYING FOR
DELIVERY THEY DON'T REALIZE THE
RESTAURANT IS ALSO PAYING A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT FOR THE
DELIVERY THEY SHOULD KNOW THAT-
THEY SHOULD KNOW. BASICALLY
THAT WHAT I JUST ORDERED WAS
ACTUALLY WHAT THE RESTAURANT IS
CHARGING SO THEY COULD CHARGE
MORE FOR A MENU ITEM THAT IS
OUT ON DELIVERY BECAUSE THEY'RE
PAYING MORE BUT THE RESTAURANT
SETTING THAT. BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
SOME OF THE APPS HAVE A CHARGE
ON ON ACTUAL ITEMS THEY KNOW
THAT THE EVERYBODY WILL KNOW
NOW THIS THIS IS A GRATUITY IT
GOES TO MY DRIVER OR THE PERSON
SERVICING ME. IN ADDITION TO
WHATEVER ELSE THEIR PAIN AT
THIS DOESN'T FULFILL THE
OBLIGATION OF THEM BEING PAID
WE JUST THINK YOU KNOW THIS IS
BEEN A VERY- HIT IN PROCESS AND
UNFORTUNATELY THESE COMPANIES
HAVE BEEN CAUGHT EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY TRYING TO. GET MORE
MONEY FOR THEM WHICH I GOT BUT
LIKE TRYING TO PULL A FAST ONE
WHETHER IT'S ON THE DRIVERS FOR
THE RESTAURANTS FOR THE
CONSUMERS AND WE JUST THINK
THAT THE TRANSPARENCY WILL
ALLOW PEOPLE TO FEEL
COMFORTABLE USING IT WILL KNOW.
WHAT IS HAPPENING. THANK LET ME
JUST NOTE IN CASE IT HELPS SOME
OF MY COLLEAGUES THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WAS GRACIOUS ENOUGH TO
ACCEPT TO ACCEPT AN AMENDMENT
AS TO THE DISCLOSURES. WHERE
THE DISCLOSURE TO THE CONSUMER
SIMPLY STATES THAT THERE WILL
BE THERE THERE IS A CHARGE TO
THE FOOD FACILITY FOR THIS
PARTICULAR SERVICE. AND ONLY IF
THE FOOD FACILITY DIRECTS THAT
MORE DETAIL BE PROVIDED BY THE
FOOD DELIVERY PLATFORM IS MORE
DETAILS. REGARDING THE
ARRANGEMENT BETWEEN THE FOOD
FACILITY AND THE DELIVERY
PLATFORM. PROVIDED SO ONLY IF
THE FOOD FACILITY. DIRECTS THAT
THE DIGITAL INFORMATION BE
PROVIDED WILL BE PROVIDED BY
THE AS A DISCLOSURE BY THE
DELIVERY PLATFORM. CENTRE BACK
FOR. EXAGGERATE CLEAR FILES FOR
MY COLLEAGUE OF MINE IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE WERE
CASES WHERE PEOPLE THOUGHT THEY
WERE PAYING TIPS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO THE DRIVERS AND
ACTUALLY WAS GOING TO THE
COMPANY ITSELF RIGHT NOW YEAH
THAT'S ONE THING THAT WILL BE
THAT PREVENTED BY THIS BILL A.
N. AND ALSO AT THAT BELIEVES
THE BILL WILL CAN IMPROVE
ECOSYSTEM ESSENTIALLY WHERE THE
RESTAURANTS WERE- AT THE POINT
WHERE THE SERVICE WAS NOT
PROFITABLE ESSENTIALLY FOR THEM
AND SO. THE HOPE IS THAT
TRANSPARENCY WILL ALSO MAKE THE
ECO SYSTEM WORK FOR EVERYONE.
YEAH ESPECIALLY THE MOM AND POP
RESTAURANTS I MEAN I. GOT YOU
KNOW WE'VE WE'VE BEEN TALKING
TO RESTAURANTS ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY'RE FACING-
OBVIOUSLY IF YOU'RE A BIG CHAIN
LKE MCDONALD'S YOU CAN YOU
KNOW THAT FIRST OF ALL THEY
HAVE A BETTER YEAH. THEY HAVE A
BETTER FEE SCHEDULE BUT THEY
CAN ALSO NEGOTIATE THIS
THEMSELVES THEY CAN TAKE CARE
OF IT BUT WHEN YOU'RE A MOM AND
POP THAT. HAD TO RELY ON
DELIVERY SERVICES AND NOW JUST
WANT YOUR CUSTOMERS TO
UNDERSTAND. YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE DEALING WITH THE OTHER
THING IS ALSO ON A PICK UP
ORDER IF YOU CALL YOU CAN CALL
THROUGH GRUBHUB FOR EXAMPLE IN
ACTUALLY GO PICK UP YOUR ORDER
YOURSELF. I THINK MOST PEOPLE
ASSUME IF I WRITE A TIP IT'S TO
THE RESTAURANT WELL THAT'S NOT
THE LAW RIGHT NOW YOU KNOW THAT
YOU WRITE A TIP IN THE APP
COMPANY TO TAKE IT SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE. THAT THAT.
BELONGS TO WHO YOU THINK YOU'RE
GIVING IT TO AND EVERYTHING
ABOUT THIS BILL IS NOT TO
PUNISH ANYONE IT IS TO PROVIDE
CONSUMERS. BUSINESSES AND-
DRIVERS WITH THE MOST AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION AND PROTECTION
ABOUT ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON SO
THAT THEY CAN MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES. SEEING
NONE OF. SENATOR MAN HAS MOVED
THE BILL SOMEONE MEMBER
GONZALEZ WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I JUST RESPECT LAST FOR
NINE MONTHS. AND LET ME SAY I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH US SO CLOSELY ON THESE
AMENDMENTS THE CHAIR WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL- THIS-MORNING THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM TEN A. B. TWO
EIGHTY SIXTY PASSES AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED RE REFERRED TO
THE CMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO REMIND YOU
TO PLEASE HAVE YOUR MICROPHONE
ON. ROSS ROSS HI MELINDA IS NO.
NO MELINDA'S NO ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D BEATS. BECKER
BACKER HI DODD BY GOD I HATE
MEN. HER TADO JONES LLEVA MEN
HI MAN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN I TELL
ABOUT OKAY. I CAN I CAN I. THE
VOTE IS SEVEN ONE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU MA'AM. THE NEXT ITEM
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE. SIR YOU
HAVE ONE BUILT TO PRESENT TODAY
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN FORTY
FOUR FOOD DELIVERY PLATFORMS
ROUND TWO. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
SENATORS I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE CHAIR FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS BILL AND I
ALSO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY WHICH ACTUALLY
MAKE OUR- CONSUMER DISCLOSURE
PROTECTIONS ACTUALLY STRONGER
SO I APPRECIATE THAT. THIS BILL
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN FORTY
FOUR TAKES A THREE PRONGED
APPROACH PROTECT CONSUMERS AND
HELP SMALL BUSINESSES EIGHT ONE
ENSURES THAT FOOD OVER
PLATFORMS IN ONLINE DIRECTORIES
PROVIDE ACCURATE BUSINESS
INFORMATION SECOND IT PROHIBITS
THIRD PARTY PLATFORMS AND
CHARGING RESTAURANTS FOR ROUTED
CALLS THAT DO NOT RESULT IN A
PAID ORDER. AND THIRDLY AND
LASTLY FOR CARS ALL FUTURE
CONTRACTS BENEFIT FOOD FACILITY
AND A FOOD DELIVERY PLATFORM
INCLUDE CLEAR INFORMATION ON
ALL POSSIBLE CHARGES OR FEES
THAT MAY BE INCURRED ON TO THE
RESTAURANT RIGHT CLICK
INFORMATION LISTING WEBSITE
WEBSITES WE PARTNER WITH THE
FOOD DELIVERY PLATFORM. HOWEVER
AS I KNOW WE JUST HAD A
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE ONLINE
ECOSYSTEM FOR SMALL RESTAURANTS
AND I JUST WANNA POINT OUT WHY
THIS BILL IS NECESSARY FOR THE
CONSUMER AND THE RESTAURANT
FROM THE CONSUMER PERSPECTIVE
IF YOU WERE TO GO ON A LISTING
WEB SITES A YELP OR GOOGLE. YOU
WOULD HOPEFULLY BE CALLING A
NUMBER WITHOUT AND WITHOUT
INCURRING MORE COSTS ONTO THE
RESTAURANT YOUR FAVORITE
RESTAURANT BUT THAT'S NOT THE
CASE OF THE PRACTICE THAT WE
ARE TRYING TO LEGISLATE. IN
EARLIER THIS YEAR YEP ITSELF
WHICH HAS A NEUTRAL POSITION AS
BILL ACTUALLY ENDED THE
PRACTICE OF CALL FORWARDING
BECAUSE THEY DID NOT WANT TO BE
SO SHE WITH THIS ANYMORE AND I
WANT TO LET YOU KNOW THAT WHY
THE DISCLOSURES ARE SO
IMPORTANT TO. IS THAT- THIS IS
AN EXAMPLE THIS ONE PAGES TWO
SIDED DOCUMENT IS EXAMPLE OF A
CONTRACT AT A RESTAURANT ENTERS
AND IT EVEN AS ON WORKS IN MUCH
THE POLICY IS VERY CONFUSING
AND- DOES NOT TALK ABOUT THE
PROJECT ACTS OF CALL
FORWARDING. AND IN A STREET
THAT HAS RAZOR THIN MARGINS AND
HAS REALLY SUFFERED DURING THE
PANDEMIC ESPECIALLY OUR API
BUSINESSES WHICH- HAVE REALLY
SUFFERED DURING THIS PANDEMIC
IT'S REALLY REALLY DIFFICULT.
THIS IS WHY IT'S NECESSARY TO
PROTECTION FOR THE SMALL
BUSINESSES AND CONSUMERS- AND
THIS IS WHY WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE
THE SUPPORT OF THE SOUL CAN.
CHAMBER COALITION MADE ABOUT
EIGHT. DIFFERENT OF COMMERCE
AND THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION DOING SOME SUPPORT.
WITH THAT I'D ALSO LIKE TO
REDUCE MY TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. THERESA KANE WHO IS
THE RESTAURANT OWNER OF. MILK
AND HONEY CAFE AND EVERYONE
CITY COUNCILMEMBER AND JAMES
SARAN WITH HISPANIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SILICON VALLEY AND
I RESPECT THE ANSWER I BUT WHEN
THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE.
WITNESSES PLEASE PROCEED. RIGHT
OKAY HELLO HI HI HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS. THERESA
KANE I AM A TAIWANESE
RESTAURANT OWNER IN THE CITY OF
FREMONT. AND I ALSO SERVE ON
THE CITY COUNCIL ND THREE
MONTHS. IN THE LAST YEAR AND A
HALF TO INDEPENDENT MAKES LOCAL
RESTAURANTS ARE AMONG THE
HARDEST HIT INDUSTRY. AND MANY
RESTAURANTS HAVE CLOSED THEIR
DOORS FOR GOOD. BUT PEOPLE RELY
HEAVILY ON DELIVERY PLATFORM.
FOR RESTAURANT OWNERS. WRITTEN
BY CHARGE ANYWAY BEING. IN FROM
FIVE TO THIRTY FOUR ON THE- TO
BE ON THE PLATFORM. FOR YELP
AND GRUBHUB BURNS. OR USING
YELP LIKE A DOUBLE PAGE NOW
RETURNS ARE BEING CHARGED WITH
DOWNLOADING WHEN CUSTOMERS.
CALL RESTAURANTS TO PLACE
ORDERS. WE APPRECIATE THE SELF
REGULATE AND PREVENT HIDDEN
CHARGES THAT PLATFORMS LIKE
WORKLOAD TARGETS RESTAURANT. BE
ON ORDERS THAT THEY DID AND
POSITIVE OR PICK UP. BECAUSE
BASICALLY THE- MALL RESTAURANTS
DON'T HAVE ATTORNEYS ON STAFF
LICENSING. AND ALSO TO JUST
TAKE IT WITHOUT ANYONE TAKING A
LEAD THEY WERE DINING ROOM FOR
NEGOTIATION. SO IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THE CONTRACTS ARE WRITTEN
FOR PROTECTION. THE RESTAURANT.
YOU SHOW YOUR SUPPORT ON THE
WELCOME TO. THANK THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. CLOSE IS JAMES
MORAN I'M LOOKING THIS IS THANK
YOU OF COMMERCE OPENED WHICH
SPONSORS SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTER AND SMALL
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT CENTERS
VATICAN VIETNAMESE SATELLITES
FOR THE SMOKING VALLEY WE ALSO
MEMBERS OF THE- MEDIA COALITION
OF- SANTA CLARA VALLEY CHAMBERS
OF COMMERCE. R. C. THREE
FOUNDATION IS THE OPERATOR OF
THE LOCAL SPDC THE SERVER HER
IDEA OF MINORITY IN MAINSTREAM
SMALL BUSINESSES WITH CHAMBER
AND SPDC. HOPE AT NINETEEN HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED THE
RESTAURANT FOOD SERVICE
BUSINESS AND WE'VE SEEN CLOSURE
RATES FROM 3250% SINCE THE
INCEPTION OF THE CODE THE
CRISIS THE BUSINESS IS ALREADY
SUFFERED GREATLY AND THEY DO
NOT NEED TO SEE FURTHER GROWTH
ON THE MARGINS OR PROFITABILITY
RESULTING FROM THIRD PARTIES.
THE AVERAGE RESTAURANT MARGIN
PROFIT MARGIN FALLS BETWEEN
325% DELIVERY AT PEACE TAKING
UP 230% COMMISSION COSTS OF
WORKING WITH THIRD PARTY
ORDERS. AS A SPORT WE
OUTWEIGHED THE BENEFITS
PREVIOUS AND RELATED REASONS
WHICH HAVE MORE SEVERELY
IMPACTED MINORITY. RESTAURANT
HOLDER COMMUNITY. I CHAMBER COM
IS PROUD SUPPORT PEOPLE FORTY
FOUR WHICH IS A DELIVERY. AND
ON DEGREE. PROVIDE ACT BUSINESS
FROM OR TO MY BUSINESS. AND
CONSUMERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU SIR NO SIR FOR MANY SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY SAYING
NO SUCH WITNESSES LET'S TURN TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN FORTY
FOUR SEEING NO WITNESSES THERE
LET'S MOVE T THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
FOURTEEN FORTY FOUR WILL BEGIN.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO THIS TIME PRESS
ONE ENTER TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. WE WILL NOW GO TO
LINE. ONE OH FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS KATIE HANSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT AND EIGHTY FOURTEEN
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. LINE. ONE OH SIX.
HI JOSH YOU TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE. ONE MOMENT
FOR THE NEXT CALLER. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED. BY ONE HUNDRED YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NEXT PLEASE.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE IN JAIL
THANK YOU LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION FIRST
THE GALLERY SEEING NO WITNESSES
THERE LET'S CHECK ROOM ONE
TWELVE WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE NO WITNESSES THERE THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN FORTY
FOUR MOBILE WE WILL MOVE
FORWARD WITH THOSE WITNESSES.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
DURING THIS TIME IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. GOING TO
GO TO LINE NINETY FIVE. DON'T
OFTEN ON BEHALF OF INTERNET
ASSOCIATION RECYCLABLES THANK
YOU. AND WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE
ONE HUNDRED NOT SURE IF THEY
ARE AWARE OF THEIR LINE NUMBER
JUST A MOMENT FIND ONE HUNDRED
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI DIDN'T.
EVEN THINK THAT THERE ARE FIVE
QUESTIONS QUOTATIONS ARE.
OPPOSED. ONE FOUR FOUR FOUR.
THANK YOU WITNESSES WILL HAVE
TO SPEAK AND SHARE THEIR-
WITNESSES WILL HAVE TO SPEAK UP
OR HAVING DIFFICULTY HEARING.
THE FUTURE THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
WOULD SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO
STAY I'M LOOKING FOR A HOLIDAY
AND I HEAR THAT WITNESS. I'M
LOOKING FOR HANNAH SMITH. AND
CAMERON CAMERON DIMITRI IF I
PRONOUNCE THAT CORRECTLY. YEAH
HERE A SECOND HERE PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING SURE
ROCKS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KENNETH
SMITH AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
CRAB I FIRST LIKE TO THANK THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
WORK ON FOURTEEN FORTY FOUR AND
REMOVING ONEROUS REQUIREMENT
FROM THIRD PARTY LISTING
WEBSITE. THE BILL WOULD NEED
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS AND WE
HAVE HEARD FROM MEMBERS AND WE
HEARD FROM MEMBERS ON JULY
SIXTH THAT THEY'RE STILL
IMPROVEMENTS TO BE MADE WE
REMAIN SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PROVISION PROHIBITING THIRD
PARTY PLATFORMS FOR CHARGING
RESTAURANTS FOR RECALL DO NOT
RESULT IN ORDERS. HOWEVER
GRAHAM HAD STRONGLY OPPOSES THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENT REQUIRING
THE DISCLOSURE OF PHONE NUMBERS
ON THIRD PARTY WITHIN MY-
CERTAINLY BELIEVES IN A FUTURE
WHERE THERE IS A VIBRANT AND
GROWING RESTAURANT COMMUNITY
AND THERE IS A BALANCE THAT IN
PERSON IN THE LIBRARY OPTIONS
FOR THEIR TEACHERS YOU'RE PART
OF THAT COMMUNITY WORKING WITH
AND ALONGSIDE A RESTAURANT
SUPPORT THEIR BROWS. SHE GOT A
CONTRACT WITH RUSSIA TO CALL
CALIFORNIA IN THE COUNTRY TO
PROVIDE. PHONE ORDERING SERVICE.
RAPID BILL REQUIRES PROPER
INSULIN TWO PHONE NUMBERS FOR
THE REST. UNIQUE PHONE. FOR THE
THIRD CONTE. TO PROVIDE. THE
RESTAURANT DIRECTION AND- E.ON
BEING CONFUSING FOR CONSUMERS.
I'M FRIGHTENED REQUIRE WOULD
HURT ABILITY FOR RESTAURANTS TO
RUN THEIR BUSINESS IN THE STATE
HE SAID. WE PROVIDE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH RESTAURANTS
AND THEY'RE ABLE TO SEE THEIR
ORDERS- AND WHO GENERATED BY
IMPLANT CUSTOM PHONE ORDER A
CUSTOM PHONE NUMBERS AND ABLE
WE ALL TIME MARKETING. AND
ALLOW FOR A RESTAURANT TO HAVE
A BETTER IDEA WHICH MARKETING
TOOLS WORK BY GENERATING THEIR
ORDERS AND WHICH ONES DO NOT.
THE NEGATIVE IMPACT OF THE BILL
GO BEYOND THE ORDER GENERATION
RESTAURANT CONTRACTOR THAT TO
PROVIDE SERVICES FOR A REASON
PRETTY QUICKLY AND ESPECIALLY
RIGHT NOW WE HEAR HOW THE
SERVICE PARTICULARLY CRITICAL
BECAUSE OF THE UNPRECEDENTED
SHORTAGE OF HOSPITALITY
STAFFERS. THE SERVICE IS ALSO
AN IMPORTANT NEED TO OVERCOMING
LANGUAGE BARRIERS FOR
RESTAURANT OWNERS AROSS
CALIFORNIA MAKE NO MISTAKE IF
THIS LEGISLATION WERE TO PASS
IT WOULD DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT MANY SMALL AN IMMIGRANT
OWNED RESTAURANT. WE'VE BEEN
ENGAGING WITH THE SPONSOR FOR
SOMETIME AND RECOGNIZE THAT THE
CELL NEED MEANINGFUL PROGRESS.
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU. MR
DIMITRI IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE.
YEAH GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WHEN IT CAME. CIOS AND
SENIOR EXECUTIVES THAT PROMOTES
THE GROWTH OF INNOVATION
ECONOMY AND REPRESENTS OVER
EIGHTY COMPANIES AND FOUR
MILLION EMPLOYEES. WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB FOURTEEN
FORTY FOUR AS WE FIND IT IS
PROBLEMATIC FOR SEVERAL REASONS.
AS REPORTED BY A. B. TWENTY ONE
FORTY NINE DOLLARS FROM LAST
YEAR. WE DELIVERY COMPANIES
HAVE CONTRACTS WITH ALL OF OUR
RESTAURANT PARTNERS PRIOR TO
LISTING THEM ON OUR SERVICE.
REQUIREMENTS OF A. B. FOURTEEN
FORTY FOUR THAT PRESCRIBE THE
EXACT TAPING CONTENT OF
ADDITIONAL DISCLOSURES THE
COMPANY NEED TO MAKE WHAT THEY
NEED CONTRACTS. TOO FAR INTO A
REALLY PRESCRIPTIVE ADDITIONAL
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS ONLY
SERVE TO MAKE THE PROCESS OF
JOINING OUR PLATFORMS MORE.
DRAWN OUT AND BURN THEM FOR
RESTAURANTS. NEED TO BE COVERED
BY BRICK RANGE OF SERVICES
AVAILABLE TO RESTAURANTS YOUR
MEMBERS PLATFORMS THEY'RE NOT A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH.
RATHER TAILORED TO EACH FRENCH.
RESTAURANTS EDITED COLLABORATE
ON MARKETING COLLATERAL
DETERMINED THE APPROPRIATE.
NEIGHBORHOODS TO OPEN NEW
LOCATIONS AND EVEN SEE HOW
PRICING AFFECTS CONSUMER DEMAND
ENTERTAINMENT RESTAURANT.
STAFFING IT HAS STORED ABOUT
THIS COULD ULTIMATELY COST OUR
PARTNERS BIBLE ORDERS AND
REVENUE. FOR THESE REASONS WE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU KNOW
ABOUT THANK YOU. MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY ON THE LINE.
MISTER CHAIR I DO NOT BELIEVE
THERE ARE. THANK YOU LET'S
BRING THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
CENTER NEWMAN. THANK YOU MR
ASSEMBLYMAN LEADS. WANT TO
COMMEND YOU FOR THIS BILL- I
USED TO WORK FOR A LONG TIME IN
THE INTERNET- AND- YOU KNOW
FOLLOW THE PROGRESSION THE
GROWTH OF SEARCH RELATED
COMPANIES LIKE GOOGLE. AND HAVE
BEEN CONTINUE PRESS OVER THE
YEARS AT. THE POWER OF THE
INTERNET PROVIDE SEARCH
CAPABILITIES BUT BUT THE SKILL
IN WHICH COMPANIES- MEDICATION
THAT FIND NEW OPPORTUNITIES TO
EXTRACT. REVENUES FROM SEARCH
THIS IS A GOOD EXAMPLE- AND SO
WHAT YOU'RE RESPONDING TO DO
HERE BY WAY OF PROVIDING
TRANSPARENCY AND DISCLOSURE- I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY
FOR. SOME OF THE RESTAURANT
CATEGORIES THAT HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED- GROUP THE RESTAURANT
BUSINESS IS A CHALLENGING
BUSINESS- EIGHTY EIGHT SMALL
MOM AND POP RESTAURANT IS.
UNDER A TON OF PRESSURE EVERY
DAY SIMPLY TO MAKE IT WORK AND
SO THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXTEND
THEIR BUSINESS THROUGH THE
INTERNET THROUGH THE OFFER OF A
PARTNER- IS A COMPELLING OFFER
BUT IT IT QUITE OFTEN DOESN'T.
YIELD THE BENEFITS. THAT ARE
PROMISED TOWARD MORE POORLY
UNDERSTOOD SO TO THE EXTENT
THAT WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
SOME RESEARCH BUT SOME MOON
CONSEILS BILL. IS PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY IN A PROPER
DISCLOSURE I THINK THAT'S A
GOOD THING- BUT I COMMEND MANY
SERVICES FOR THE FOR THE VALUE
THAT THEY PROVIDE BUT IN THIS
IMPORTANT AT THE RESTAURANTS
AND THEIR CONSUMERS ARE FULLY
AWARE OF WHAT- THE NUMBER THEY
ARE CALLING INCIDENT AND WHAT
THAT ENTAILS THAT SHE'LL BE IN
A CLASS WITH THE BILL TODAY
GLAD TO MOVE IT WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE- AND I WOULD ASK
YOU. ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR IF
THAT'S POSSIBLE. I LOVE TO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO NEWMAN
I SEE. US AND FAN. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND- SOME REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
THINK WHAT YOU KNOW IF THERE'S
A CERTAINLY LOVE THE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
RESTAURANTS AND THE- AND THE-
DELIVERY COMPANY AREN'T- APPS.
OR IS ASIAN BUT WE SHOULD THINK
ABOUT THE CONSUMER TO AM I MEAN
BY THAT IS THAT. CERTAINLY IS A
CONSUMER I'D LIKE TO ACTUALLY
HAVE SOME CHOICE LIKE WHO I
SUPPORT WITH MY SPENDING
DOLLARS AND I THINK MANY
CONSUMERS FEEL THAT WAY. AND
SO- I THINK BLACK CONSUMERS
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THAT IF THEY
GO TO A RESTAURANT AND THEY
MAKE A CALL AND THE CALL
NUMBER- WHERE THE MONEY IS
GOING IN THE SENSE THAT IF THEY
GIVE A TIP OR SOME OTHER THING
IS IT WHO'S GOING TO WRITE AND
I THINK THE- PEOPLE HAVE
PERCEPTIONS OF WHAT I THINK
IT'S GOING BUT IT'S NOT GOING
WHERE PEOPLE PERCEIVE- THAT-
THEN- THAT CAN BE A BIT
DECEPTIVE SO. I DO APPRECIATE
THIS EFFORT AT TRANSPARENCY-
FEATURE YOUR WORK AT TO TRY TO
BE SURE THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO WORK SMOOTHLY.
BUT ALSO CERTAINLY IS A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER APPRECIATE
BECAUSE OFTENTIMES SMALL
BUSINESS DON'T HAVE LEVERAGE I
THINK MOST IMPORTANTLY IS THAT-
CONSUMERS. ACTUALLY- KIDS OF
PEOPLE THEY WANT SUPPORT AND
THEY CHOOSE NOT TO THEY AN
CHOOSE NOT TO BUT- LET'S LET'S
GIVE BE SURE TO CONSUMER HAVE
SAYS TRANSPARENCY CHOICE. AND
THAT SO THANK YOU. SERVER THANK
YOU I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT TO
YOU KNOW DO YOU TAKE THE
CONCERN SERIOUSLY OF TECHNICAL
TERMS RAISED I DO APPRECIATE
AND HAVE A LOT OF CONVERSATION
WITH THE AUTHOR AND APPRECIATE
THE MINUTES THAT YOU'VE MADE-
TO- WORK TO CLARIFY A LOT INTO
TWO MOVIES BEFORE SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER AGAIN THANK
YOU. IN DECEMBER THE TALK TO ME
TALK TALK ME THROUGH THE
ENFORCEMENT COMPONENT OF THIS
RIGHT SO IS THAT THE CHARGES
ONLY HAPPENED IF- PURCHASES
MADE. HOW DO WE TRACK THAT HAD
WE KNOWN HOW IS THAT IMPORTANT
YEAH ACCORDING TO GRUBHUB
ITSELF THEY ALREADY THEY
ALREADY ARE ABLE TO WERE WERE
ABLE TO- RECORD RECORD PHONE
CALLS ABLE TO TRACK THAT AND
THERE IS A MECHANISM IN WHICH
BUSINESS OWNERS CAN DISPUTE
SAID CALLS RIGHT TO SAY I
CALLED YOUR BURGER RESTAURANT
AND I JUST THREW THE BEFOREHAND
WHEN THAT THIS WAS A PRACTICE
ON YELP- AND I CALLED A GROUP
OF PHONE NUMBER AND I SAID HEY.
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU GUYS CLOSE
TODAYYOU KNOW AND I JUST HUNG
UP AFTER THAT THERE COULD BE
COULD AND THERE ARE ALLEGED
ALLEGATIONS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
NOW WHERE THERE ARE DUBIOUS
CHARGES LIKE THAN THE
RESTAURANTS THE RESTAURANTS CAN
OF COURSE GO THROUGH THE
RECORDS AND CHECK YOU CAN ALSO
IMAGINE A SMALL MOM PA PLAN A
SMALL MOM AND POP RSTAURANT
SITUATION HOW ONEROUS AND
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO GO TO
CATCH THOSE THINGS. AND ALSO
SOMETHING TO MENTION IS THIS
CALL FORWARDING HAD BEEN LUMPED
UNDER WHAT THEY HAD CALLED A
MARKETING COMMISSION OUR
MARKETING FEE THAT IS SINGLE
HIGHEST COMMISSION INDIANS
HIGHER ORDERING- JUST FOR
REFERENCE BECAUSE I HAVE THE
MODEL BILL THAT COMES FROM
REPUBLIC SO. MARKETING WAS 20%
OF EVERY ORDER DELIVERY WAS 10%
ONLINE ORDERING LINK WAS ONE
DOLLAR AND THE MICROSITE WHICH
NOTHING IS ONE DOLLAR JUST FLAT
FEE MARKETING ITSELF IN THE
CONTRACTS IN THE CONTRACT THEY
GIVE TO. THE RESTAURANTS WHICH
IS IN VERY TINY FONT CAN EVEN
SEE IT FROM HERE- HAS A VERY
VAGUE MENTION OF CALL
FORWARDING AT BEST I COULD
ARGUE AND IT'S NOT VERY CLEAR
THAT THAT HAPPENS RIGHT SO WHEN
YOU'RE HOARDING SET TEN DOLLAR
BURGER AND 20% OF THAT IS ON
MARKETING THIS TWO DOLLARS
RIGHT THERE AND I HAD A LOT OF
THE MARGIN SO THERE ARE
MECHANISMS IN WHICH THEY
ALREADY CLAIM TO HAPPEN AND
ALSO BROKE UP SAYS AS A MATTER
OF POLICY. THEY DON'T CHARGE
BUT HE DIDN'T THEY DON'T CHARGE
PHONE CALLS. THAT DON'T RESULT
IN ORDER AND WE'RE GONNA FIND
OUT NOW. THE TO THE CHAIR ARE
YOU ARE YOU THEN IS THE IS THE-
THAT THAT. PER MARKET. THAT
ONLY FOR THE CALL FORWARDING OR
OR IS THAT NOT. IS THAT 20% IN
MARKETING NOT ALSO OTHER FORMS
OF ADVERTISING AND LISTING OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT. SO THE 20%
MARKETING FEE INCLUDES ALMOST
EVERY ANYTHING IN ITS LEGAL
DEFINITION OF THE TERMS IT
COULD BE EVERYTHING FROM ONLINE
ADVERTISEMENTS PHONE CALL EVEN
USER AT IT COULD BE ANYTHING
BUT CALL FORWARDING IS ALSO
LISTED THERE SO IF YOU ARE A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER. YOU GOT
TO REALLY DISSECT WHAT THAT
CHARGES AND WHAT THAT MEANS
OKAY SO IT'S NOT THIS TWENTY
FIRST IS NOT 20% MARKUP FOR
THAT CALL FORWARDING. IT TWENTY
SEVEN MARKETING AND THAT CALL
<c.cyan>ORWARDING COULD BE A COMPONENT</c>
OF THAT 20% YES JUST TO BE
CLEAR THIS BILL DOES NOT BAN
THE PRACTICE- CALL FORWARDING.
SO LONG AS IT RESULTS IN. AN
UNPAID ORDER AND ALSO YOU KNOW
A LISTING WHICH THEY COULD
STILL DO IT SO LONG AS THE
ACCURATE INFORMATION ACCURATE
PHONE NUMBER. THANK YOU SENATOR
SIR MELINDA'S. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS SO WHAT YOU DO YOU
TALKED ABOUT- SPACE A CUSTOMER
CALLS AND ASKS WHAT TIME DO YOU
CLOSE TODAY AND THEY HNG UP
AND THEN A RESTAURANT COULD BE
CHARGED FOR THAT CALL SO. I
GUESS I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
THE LOGISTICS OF THIS HOW DOES
A RESTAURANT OWNER IF THEY ARE
GOING TO GO THROUGH THE CALLS
AND THE CHARGES HOW WOULD THEY
KNOW THAT A CALL. THAT SOMEONE
CALLED IN AND ONLY ASKED WHAT
TIME THEY CLOSE AS OPPOSED TO
SOMEBODY CALLED IN AND PLACED
AN ORDER. IT'S A GREAT QUESTION
I DON'T KNOW IF MY WITNESS
RECESS STILL ON OR ANY OF MY
WITNESSES IF THEY WANT
EXPLAINED ON. THE LIKE DID A
LOGISTICAL PART I WOULDN'T KNOW
AS NOT A RESTAURANT OWNER BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE STILL ON
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND HOW. A
RESTAURANT OWNER COULD DISCERN
BETWEEN A CALL THEY SHOULD E
CHARGED FOR IN A CALL THAT
PERHAPS THEY SHOULD NOT RIGHT
AND I MEAN JUST TO PRACTICE IF
THEY SAY YEAH THAT'S THE
FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM IS MOST THE
TIME IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
DISCERN- I DON'T KNOW IF
THEY'RE- STILL ON. WELL MY I
GUESS MA'AM PERHAPS WHILE WE
WAIT FOR HER IF SHE'S GOING TO
COME BACK ON THE LINE- I READ
THROUGH THE CONTRACT. AND I
THINK THERE'S A SUGGESTION THAT
PERHAPS WITH THE SMALLER
RESTAURANTS- WHO DON'T HAVE A
STAFF ATTORNEY THAT THEY'RE
UNABLE TO DECIPHER YOU KNOW THE
LEGALESE WITHIN THAT CONTRACT
BUT I I'M NOT SURE IF THIS IS
THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE IN SO. YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON
AND I DON'T I DON'T KNOW THAT
IT'S APPROPRIATE TO SUGGEST
THAT BECAUSE IT'S A SMALL
BUSINESS AND THEY DON'T HAVE A
STAFF ATTORNEY THAT THEY'RE NOT
STILL REQUIRED- AND BOUND TO.
UNDERSTAND THE CONTRACT THAT
THEY'RE SIGNING PERHAPS RUN IT
BY YOU KNOW SOMEONE SO THAT
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY'RE AGREEING
TO BECAUSE IT IS A CONTRACT
BETWEEN THE TWO PARTIES- SO I'M
WONDERING IS YOUR WITNESS IS
COMING BACK. ANYONE BY HE
WITNESS IS STILL ON THE LINE MR
DURAN. WITNESS TO RESERVE. OKAY
YES HELLO HI- SO ACTUALLY- WE
HAVE NO WAY OF TELLING YOU KNOW
WELL AT THE TIME OF THE CALL
WHETHER YOU KNOW IT'S A CALL
COMING IN FROM BUT PROBABLY NOT
AND YOU KNOW THERE'S DIFFERENT
STAFF WORKING IN YOU KNOW WE
JUST DON'T HAVE THE TIME AND AN
EFFORT. TO OKAY THING WHICH THE
CALLS AND THEN YOU KNOW. WHERE
YOUR RANKING ABOUT. HI WE WOULD
USE CHARGES OR- THANK YOU THANK
YOU MA'AM I APPRECIATE YOUR-
PROVIDING CLARITY SO YOU SEE
THE PROBLEM THAT I'M HAVING
HERE IS THAT YOU'RE SAYING
SOMEONE COULD YOU KNOW THEY
THEY MAY BE GETTING CHARGED FOR
BECAUSE THEY SHOULDN'T BE
GETTING CHARGED FOR BUT IT
DOESN'T APPEAR THAT THERE'S ANY
WAY FOR A RESTAURANT TO- OR ONE
OF THESE PLATFORMS TO BE ABLE
TO SAY. YES THIS WAS A
LEGITIMATE CHARGER NO THIS
WASN'T I DON'T KNOW HOW. I YEAH
HOW YOU SOLVE THAT PROBLEM BUT
YEAH- IS THAT I'M IN. A SEVEN
EXCUSE ME MA'AM IF SOME WOMEN
ONLY IF YOU COULD. ADDRESS
THAT. I THINK YOU HAVE A VERY.
IT'S A VALID CONCERN ABOUT IT
BUT I THINK WITHIN THE SCOPE OF
THE COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
BAPTIZING SMALL BUSINESSES AND
IN A PERFECT WORLD WE ARM
CONSUMERS AND BUSINESSES WITH
THE MOST INFORMED BUT THE MOST
INFORMATION LIKE MOST INFORMED
DECISIONS RIGHT BUT WE KNOW IN
REAL LIFE AND IN PRACTICE THAT
DOES NOT EXIST AND ESPECIALLY
EXISTS FOR SMALL BUSINESSES AS
YOU HEARD WHO. YOU KNOW RIGHT
NOW ARE HAVING STAFFING
DIFFICULTIES ARE HAVING
DIFFICULTY BEING UP WITH THE
ONLINE ENVIRONMENT AS WELL SO
IT'S NOT A PERFECT ENVIRONMENT
AND HASN'T EVEN MENTIONED YOU
KNOW THERE IS A BOUNTY THERE IS
A THERE IS A TEMPTATION TO GO
ONLINE PLATFORM SURVIVE AND WE
THRIVE BUT PERHAPS A LOT OF
TIMES THEY ARE SIGNING UP FOR
THEY ARE GETTING EXACTLY THE
SIGN UP FOR AND THAT'S THE CASE
A LOT OF BUSINESSES THAT GO ON.
THIRD PARTY PLATFORMS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THAT'LL HAVE
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU
SENATOR. I SEE NO OTHER MIKES
UP. SO WITH SOME REMEMBER LEE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION AND WE- HOPE THAT WE
CAN BE A PASS THIS BILL. THEY
ARE SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
DEFINITELY STILL HURTING. AND I
DO THINK THAT- REMOTE ORDERING
WHETHER BE TELEPHONICALLY OR
DIGITAL IS HERE TO STAY FOR THE
NUMEROUS CONSUMERS GAIN MORE
MORE USED TO IT. SO WE SHOULD
BE EQUIPPING CONSUMERS AND
SMALL BUSINESSES ALIKE WITH AS
MUCH INFORMATION TRANSPARENCY
AS POSSIBLE. AND AGAIN THANK.
THE CHAIR FOR HIS. AMENDMENTS
AND DISCLOSURE BECAUSE I DO
THINK THE- THE SUGGESTION
FOURTEEN POINT. FOURTEEN POINT
FIVE IS GREAT BECAUSE I'M A
CURRENT CONTRACT LANGUAGE MUST
BE IN POINT. SIX OR SOMETHING
BECAUSE IF. IF IT NOW SAYS HIS
POINT TEN IT'S MUCH LESS OF
THAT SO THANK YOU SO MUCH AND-
TONIGHT FOLKS. THANK YOU SIR
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THOSE
AMENDMENTS. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR NEWMAN THE MOTION. IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FILE ITEM ELEVEN A. B.
FOURTEEN FORTY FOUR DEEP PASSES
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
ROSS ROSS I MELINDA'S.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I'D BEAT TH
BECKER. BECKER I DIED. EIGHT
MEN BY. ADMIN I HER TADO HOW
HER TADO I'D JONES. LEAVE US.
MAIN ON MAIN LINE NEWMAN ALL
RIGHT NEWMAN I TELL ABOUT OKAY
HAN BY HAND HI. BILL IS EIGHT
VOTES WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
SIR. LET'S TAKE FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RUBIO. WELCOME YOU HAVE TWO
BILLS TO PRESENT TODAY LET'S
START WITH YOUR FIRST BILL
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FIFTEEN
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READING
THEM. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- SEE- IT BE TEN FIFTEEN
CODIFIES RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITORS-
RELATING TO THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING ENROLLMENT
DECISIONS FOR NEW AND EXISTING
NURSING PROGRAMS. AT CALIFORNIA
LOOKS TO ADDRESS BOTH REGIONAL
AND PROJECTED STATEWIDE NURSING
SHORTAGES THE BEER AND SHOULD
BE USING ALL AVAILABLE TOOLS TO
ENSURE EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE
ENROLLMENT. OF NURSING STUDENTS
IN PRE LICENSING- PROGRAMS. THE
B. R. M. PLAYS AN ESSENTIAL
ROLE IN OVERSEEING CALIFORNIA'S
PRE LICENSURE NURSING PROGRAM
AND IN THE AUDIT OF THE BEER
AND WHICH WAS REQUESTED BY ME
AND SUPPORTED BY MANY MEMBERS.
OF THIS COMMITTEE BACK IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THERE WERE
CLEAR AND ADEQUATE FEES. IN THE
WAY THE B. R. AND REVIEWS PRE
LICENSURE PROGRAMS ON THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE STATE
ARBITERS FINDINGS AB TEN
FIFTEEN DOES THREE THINGS
NUMBER ONE REQUIRES THE BEER
AND TO INCORPORATE REGIONAL
FORECASTS INTO. ITS BY- BY
ANNUAL THAT ANALYSIS OF THE
NURSING WORKFORCE NUMBER TWO
REQUIRES THE B. R. AND TO
DEVELOP A PLAN TO ADDRESS
REGIONAL AREAS OF SHORTAGE
IDENTIFIED BY ITS NURSING
WORKFORCE FORECAST. AND
IDENTIFY ADDITIONAL FACILITIES
THAT COULD OFFER CLINICAL
PLACEMENT SPOTS AND NUMBER
THREE REQUIRES THE B. R. INTO
ANNUALLY COLLECT ANALYZE AND
REPORT INFORMATION RELATED TO
THE NUMBER OF CLINICAL
PLACEMENT SLOTS THERE ARE
AVAILABLE AND THE LOCATION OF
THOSE CLINICAL PLACEMENTS LOTS
WITHIN THE STATE. WELL THE
NURSING WORKFORCE AND
EDUCATIONAL PATHWAYS ARE
COMPLEX ARE COMPLEX ISSUES THAT
WILL REQUIRE ONGOING TWEAKS
THIS WOULD BE ONE MORE TOOL AT
THE STATE'S DISPOSAL TO HELP
PREDICT AN ADDRESS SHORTAGES
FOR THE STATE EXPECT THE- FOR
THE- SHORTAGES THE STATE IS
EXPECTING IN THE FUTURE. THIS
BILL HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT RECEIVING
ZERO NO VOTES AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR AN IPHONE
TO. THANK YOU NO TURN TO
SUPPORT. FIRST TO THE GALLERY
OR THERE ANY SUPPORT. IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NONE LET'S TURN
TO WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN FIFTEEN SITTING NONE LET'S
MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT. ANY INDIVIDUALS
WAVING TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FIFTEEN. WE
WILL BEGIN. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
ZERO EIGHT. THANK YOU TO
REMEMBER THEIR BRIDGE ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. MISTER CHAIR THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE COULD SIGNAL THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU
LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS
AND HEAR FROM ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION FIRST WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY.
SAYING NO SUCH WITNESSES
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE. I
SEE NONE LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FIFTEEN. WE
WILL MOVE FORWARD WITH THOSE
WITNESSES. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE.
YOUR CHAIR KNOWING THE SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO STAY THANK
YOU LET'S BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN
THE SENATE CHAMBER. FIRST
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
FIRST SENATOR EDMUND. I THINK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR I
WOULD JUST MOVE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. CENTER OF
TROUBLE. MMHM GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING YEP. I REPRESENT A
VERY RURAL DISTRICT THAT IS
SEVERELY IMPACTED BY SHORTAGES
IN HEALTH CARE WORKERS SO I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
FORWARD I WOULD LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR IF YOU
HAVE THE CHANCE MOVING FORWARD
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS I SEE NO OTHER MAKES
UP. SOME REMEMBER RUBIO ME YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I PUT.
AND WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
EGGMAN. THE MOTION IS DEPRESSED
REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FIVE ELEVEN TWELVE EIGHTY
TEN FIFTEEN DEPRESSING REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ROTH. ROSS I'D
MELINDA'S ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA
EYED PEAS DR. BACKER I. DODD
DOT I. EIGHT MIN A MAN I HER
TADO- TAUGHT A WIDE JONES LIZA
MEN. MEN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN I I'D
SHOW A VOGUE A SHOWBOAT IPN HE
AND I. THE THIRD VOTES WILL
THAT MEASURE OPENS FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU MA'AM THANK
YOU YOUR NEXT MAJOR FILE ADAM
NUMBER THIRTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN SENATORS I THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
TODAY ON ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT AN ACT RELATING TO
ENFORCEMENT OF UNLICENSED. POT
CANNABIS BUSINESSES I WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING GOD
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS MEASURE
AND VERBALLY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS LISTED IN
COMMENT SIX OF THE ANALYSIS
SENATORS CURRENTLY AT OUR
CURRENT ESTIMATES PUT THE VALUE
OF THE LEGAL CANNABIS MARKET AT
AROUND EIGHT POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS. PER YEAR
ACCOUNTING FOR ALMOST 80% OF
TOTAL- CANNABIS SALES IN THE
STATE ALL OF THIS ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY IS BOTH UNTAXED AND
UNREGULATED IN ADDITION TO
DWINDLING TAX REVENUES THE
UNDERGROUND MARKET PRESENTS A
SERIOUS THREAT TO PUBLIC HEALTH
AS PRODUCTS SOLD AT THESE
LOCATIONS EBATES STATE TESTING
REQUIREMENTS A. B. ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT WILL ESTABLISH SO-
CIVIL FINES. FOR THOSE WHO
OPERATES A- OPERATE SUPPORT AND
SUPPORT THESE DISPENSARIES
AMENDMENTS TAKEN SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE CLEARLY AND
EXPLICITLY PROTECT LOW LEVEL
EMPLOYEES AT CANNABIS
OPERATIONS AND PROVIDE DUE
PROCESS PROTECTIONS BEFORE A
FINE IS ASSESSED THE BILL HAS
ENJOYED THE SUPPORT OF LABOR
UNIONS WHO REPRESENT THESE
EMPLOYEES THE LEGITIMATE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THE BILL HAS ALSO RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT TO
THIS POINT IN THE PROCESS WITH
ME TODAY I HAVE A ARE THERE TO
REGAL ON BEHALF OF THE UNITED
FOOD AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS AND
MARVIN PLAYED ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED CANNABIS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE
THANK YOU WE WILL MOVE. ONTO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF YOUR
BILL A REMINDER TO ALL
WITNESSES THAT WE ARE LIMITED
TO THREE MINUTES AND SUPPORT
THREE MINUTES IN OPPOSITION AND
AS NOTED THIS MEASURE ENJOYS A
SUPPORT SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION.
SO WITNESSES. PLEASE YEAH
REMEMBER A GOOD NUMBER TO. I'LL
GO AHEAD AGAIN HM NUMBER SMART
INTERNET ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED CANNABIS BOOK PEACH AND
IT'S PART OF THE BILL. I'M
CURRENTLY AT AND IF THE MARKET
MAKES UP 70% OF THE CANADA
MARKET. HI PROVIDES THE
NECESSARY TOOLS FOR GOVERNMENTS
TO PROTECT. OUR COMMUNITIES
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR WHAT THE
KNACK IT WITHOUT TOOLS TO
ENFORCE AGAINST ELECTED
OPERATORS. NINE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED EIGHTY NINETY SEVEN.
WHICH IS SIMILAR TO THE-
MEASURE WHICH STATE THE AGENCY
THE AUTHORITY TO IMPOSE.
PENALTIES AGAINST IT BT
OPERATORS. HOWEVER STATE AGENCY
ON HOW TO PACK YOUR RESOURCES
TO ENFORCE. I CAN'T DISCONNECT
OPERATORS WE CONTINUE TO SEE A
BIG PROBLEM. THE STATE FACES A
WATER CRISIS. ILLICIT CANNABIS
GROWERS CONTINUE TO OPERATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT OUR DEMAND
WHAT THEY COULD DO. I DID THAT
STATION. WILL HELP TOO I. A IF
PROTECTED ARE CRIME I CANNOT
OPERATE THE HIGH. HIGH NINETY
T. THEN. COULD PAY WHICH IS TWO
OR- WHICH UP FILM WHICH IT HARD
TO COMPETE WITH THEM HI THIS
YEAR IN BUDGET CLOSE TO ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS- FROM
CANADA HAD WHO ARE LOOKING FOR
CHILDCARE. I'D BE HAPPY REVENUE
WOULD POTENTIALLY INCREASE
WANTED AT THE MARKET THE CREEK
IS HOW WE NEED THIS LEGISLATION
IN ORDER TO I CAN HAVE IT
ILLEGAL OPERATIONS TO COURAGE.
WHO'S BACK G. ASTRONOMICAL.
THANK YOU SIR NICK PLEASE.
RICHARD SHERMAN TO MORNING THIS
ALBERTA RECALL MAY HAVE PUT A
UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS ALL IN SUPPORT AND
PROUD SPONSOR LEGISLATION IT'S
BEEN A BEEN IN THE WORKS FOR
THREE YEARS SO. VERY HAPPY TAKE
AMENDMENTS TO PROTECT EMPLOYEES
AND THAT'S OUR THAT'S OUR
PRINCIPAL CONCERN IS RAISING
THE STANDARD OF LIVING IN THIS
GROWING AND BURGEONING INDUSTRY
NUMBER TWO THOUGH THE- YOU KNOW
THAT THAT OPPOSITION IS VERY
THEY RAISE CONCERNS NOT ABOUT
EMPLOYEES BUT ABOUT A QUICK UP
AGAINST ONE OF THE MAJOR
IMPEDIMENTS TO. PEOPLE OF COLOR
FROM GETTING INTO THE BUSINESS
IS THE ILLICIT OPERATORS AS OF
DECEMBER RUBIO'S NOTICE- SO IT
WAS A MARKET PLACE ON NUMBERS
OF LEGAL MARKETPLACE BY A
FACTOR OF THREE OR FOUR TO ONE
SO THIS IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE
TO HELP US IN ENFORCING
MEASURES AND TO MAKE SURE THAT-
THAT ALL OF THE BUSINESSES IN
THE CANNABIS SPACED ARE
LICENSED AND- PROPERLY
REGULATED BUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I WOKE. THANK YOU SIR
HELLO SIR FROM ANY SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY I SEE
NO WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT SEEING NO
WITNESSES THERE TURNING TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WOULDN'T
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF A SYMBOL.
OF THEM THIRTY EIGHT WE WILL
BEGIN. FOR THOSE WHO WERE TO
SPEAK. SPEAKING TO. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. WE GO TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND ELEVEN. RESEARCHER
MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF CMG KHALIFAN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
LINE. EIGHTY MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ANY FRANCO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION STRONG
SUPPORT. FOR THEIR WORK ON THE
KITCHEN THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
RIGHT LINE. THIRTY ONE. FINE
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME PERFECTLY
PLACED ACID HELLO. HELLO THIS
IS JOHN COMPATIBLE REPRESENTING
OF SAN FRANCISCO CANNABIS
RETAILERS AS WELL DOWN TO SOME
OF THE STRONG SUPPORT OF ITSELF
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. FINE. SEVENTY
THREE. MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I'M JIM WORLEY
REPRESENTING THE COMMUNITY
WATER SYSTEMS ALLIANCE WHOSE
MEMBERS ARE GRAPPLING WITH AN
EXPLOSION OF ILLICIT CANNABIS
CULTIVATION IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA DESERT AS SUCH WE
ARE SUPPORTIVE AT ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. SURE THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU LET'S FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE FOR
MANY OPPOSITION FIRST BEGINNING
WITH WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
SAYING NONE LET'S GO TO.
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO A SYMBOL OF IN THIRTY EIGHT
I SEE NO SUCH WITNESSES. LET'S
MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU WILL
PLEASE PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUAL'S
WAY TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE. WE WILL PROCEED
WITH THEM. THOSE OF YOU WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO
SPEAK NOT FISHING PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. MISTER CHAIR
KNOWING A SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK LET'S NOT BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
CENTER ON JULY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAR I'D LIKE TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR I AM A-
TOTAL AGREEMENT WITH THE- ABC
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT AND I WOULD
LOVE TO BE AN OFF THE CO
AUTHOR- IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
PROTECT THOSE.WHO ARE DOING
THINGS CORRECTLY BY THE LAW BUY
THE BOOK AND SOME OF THESE
BUSINESSES. THAT ARE BEING
PUSHED TO THE SIDE BY ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY. IT MUST STOP I THINK
THIS IS A GREAT IDEA WHERE TO
GO FORWARD WITH IT. AND I HOPE
TO BE A AS I MENTIONED THE COLD
WATER THANK THANK YOU AND- I
WILL MOVE IT AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU SEARCH LOTUS AT
HER TOES. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
I'VE- WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
I ALSO WANT TO- YOU STRESS THAT
WE'RE IN A DROUGHT AT THE
MOMENT THERE'S A LOT OF ILLEGAL
GIRLS OCCURRING ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- AND YOU
KNOW WE ALL KNOW THAT IT TAKES
WATER TO GROW SO. I THINK THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT STEP TO
TAKE AND HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD WHEN- WHEN IT WHEN
WE'RE READY TO DO SO AND- ALSO
HAPPY TO JOIN AS A CO AUTHOR
OF. THE FALLOUT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR CENTER OF
TOTAL. LIKEWISE I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND A TOWN
HALL MEETING THIS PAST WEEKEND
IN MY DISTRICT ALONG WITH A
COUPLE OF THE FAMILY MEMBERS-
IN THE END- HERE TODAY
ACTUALLY. AND I HAVE TO SAY
IT'S GOTTEN OUT OF CONTROL AND
I HEARD FROM MANY CONSTITUENTS
WITH REGARDS TO THEIR- CONCERNS
AND WHAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
SEEING AND EXPERIENCING IN
THERE SO ON BEHALF OF THOSE
CONSTITUENTS AND CONCERNS THAT
THEY HAVE I THINK YOU FOR
MOVING THIS MEASURE FORWARD
AND- WOULD LOVE TO BE FED UP
WITH THE COOPERS WELL. THANK
YOU SENATOR I SEE NO OTHER
MIKES UP. SO SENATOR MEAN
SENATOR MAYBE NEVER HAD. SOME
REMEMBER RUBIO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSETHANK YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE ALL THE COMMENTS AND
WOULD LOVE TO- ADD AS OF
COLLECTORS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A NIGHT OUT. THE BILL'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR ARCHER
LET OF THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED REFER
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN AB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
DO YOU PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED WE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ROTH R. ROSS I'M MELINDA'S
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA IBEATS
BECKER. BACKER I. DODD DOT I.
EIGHT MEN HER TADO FURTADO I'D
JONES JONES I. LEIVA. I MEAN
MAN HI NEWMAN NEW MAN I CHILL
ABODE UNTIL ABOUT- GUIDE HAN
HAN I. BILL HAS TEN VOTES WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU. BELIEVER ON
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SOLACE. SO YOU HAVE ONE
BILL TO PRESENT TODAY ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR ZERO SEVEN. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB FLORAL
SEVEN LOOKS BANNED ACCESS TO
QUALITY EYE CARE BY.
AUTHORIZING OPTOMETRISTS TO
TREAT ADDITIONAL CONDITIONS OF
THE I. THAT IS- WELL WITHIN
THEIR TRAINING SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILL UPDATES AND
CONSOLIDATES THE CURRENT LIST
OF CONDITIONS AND NOT
PUBLISHERS. THAT TO BE ABLE TO
TREAT. BY BY ALLOWING LICENSED
OPTOMETRISTS APPEARED TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CLEAR WAVE
TESTS FOR. CONDITIONS RELATED
TO THE ARTHRITIS TREATMENT
UTILIZING LIGHT THERAPY FOR DRY
ICE PREVENTS THE USE OF FDA
APPROVED MEDICATIONS AND ALLOWS
OPTOMETRISTS PROVIDE THE CODE
NINETEEN VACCINE. IN ADDITION
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW MEDICAL
SYSTEMS PERFORM SUBJECTIVE
REFRACTION UNDER SUPERVISION-
AND I DO HAVE A TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. HI MISTER CHAIR I HAVE
ON THE LINES OF THE TERRY
MCHALE WITH CALIFORNIA
OPTOMETRIC ASSOCIATION AND JOE
LANG WITH CALIFORNIA. ACADEMY
OF EYE PHYSICIANS AND SURGEONS.
WELL THANK YOU WILL MOVE ON TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF YOUR
MEASURE I WILL NOTE FOR THE
RECORD THAT THIS. BILL ENJOYS
SUPPORT SUPPORT SUPPORT
RECOMMENDATIONS SO FOR PURPOSES
OF TIME PERHAPS THAT WILL
INFORM OUR WITNESS TESTIMONY. A
GERMAN PLEASE PROCEED. MISTER
CHAIRMAN TERRY MCHALE IN THERE
AND WE CAN ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE OPTOMETRIC
ASSOCIATION. AND I WILL TAKE
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND BE
VERY VERY BRIEF EIGHTY FOUR OH
SEVEN IS THE PRODUCT OF
LEGISLATIVE STAFF CONVENING
EVERY THURSDAY FOR THE LAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
THE ACADEMY OF OPHTHALMOLOGY.
IN CMA TO SAFELY AND
RESPONSIBLY EXPAND OPTOMETRIC
SCOPE OF PRACTICE IN
CALIFORNIA. IT ENJOYS UNIVERSAL
SUPPORT AND I ASK YOU TO PLEASE
SUPPORT IT TODAY ALSO. THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOE LANG
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF EYE PHYSICIANS
SURGEONS- FOLLOWING THE SERVER
KILLED PLEASE YES WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS BILL ACTUALLY
FOR. MANY MONTHS AND WE HAVE
COME TO AN AGREEMENT-
SIGNIFICANT. FRANCISCO WILL I
THINK ALLOW FOR ADDITIONAL
PROCEDURES TO BE DONE ABOUT THE-
MISSIONS ACCOMPLISHED CAN TREAT
AS WELL AS- THE DEVICES AND
TECHNIQUES THEY CAN USE IN
TREATING THEM. BUT WE DO
SUPPORTABILITY SIPPING GOOD
COLLABORATIVE GOOD FAITH
DISCUSSIONS WE DO HAVE A FEW
ADDITIONAL IMPORTANT ISSUES TO
DISCUSS THE BILL RIGHT NOW IS
IN FINE SHAPE AND WE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR WILL NOW TURN TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
GALLERY. SAYING NO WITNESSES
STANDING IN SUPPORT ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WAS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
ZERO SEVEN SINGLE WITNESSES
THEY'RE TURNING TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT. ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR ZERO SEVEN.
WE WILL BEGIN. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE POINT. ZERO SURE NO ONE HAS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU LET'S FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE FOR
MANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES FIRST
IN THE GALLERY. SITTING NO
WITNESSES ROOM ONE TWELVE
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO THE ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR ZERO SEVEN I SEE NO
WITNESSES THERE TURNING TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE NOW
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE. WE WILL PROCEED
WITH THEM. FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN. ZERO
THE FUTURE KNOWING THE SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO STAY. OKAY
LET'S NOT BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
REGARDING THIS MEASURE. CENTER
HER TADO. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR.
FOR THIS MEASURE AND WOULD LIKE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AND
THIS BILL IS IT'S VERY PERSONAL
ONE FOR ME AND I WANT TO THANK
THEM ONCE AGAIN FOR. BRINGING
THE MEASURE FOR. MAY I ALSO
TAKE THAT AS A MOTION SENSOR. I
DON'T KNOW I DON'T KNOW BUT-
THAT IS OUR MOTION ON THE BILL-
CENTER DOT IT IS STAND UP
FIRST. HE GETS A CHANCE.
SEPTEMBER SAUCE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE- YES JUST PRE SHE
WOULD LOVE TO ADD THE CENTER ON
AS A CO AUTHOR PRE SHAPE THAT
IT WILL DO WANT TO THANK ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS THIS IS BEEN A
LABOR OF LOVE. IT'S BEEN MANY
MONTHS I WOULD SAY MANY YEARS
AND IN THE MAKING AND FOR J.
EVERYBODY'S ASSISTANCE ON THIS.
BUT WE COULD HAVEA NON
CONTROVERSIAL BUT SIGNIFICANT
BILL MOVING FORWARD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MICHAEL
THANK YOU BILL'S BEENMOVED BY
SENATOR DODD THE MOTION IS TO
PASS REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. I I'M FORTY A BEEF.
OH SEVEN DO YOU PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ROTH. ROSS I
MELINDA'S. ARCHULETA ALL RIGHT.
OCALAN I'D BEAT. BECKER HI.
BECKER I DAUGHTER. BY GOD I
EXAMINE. HER TADO. FURTADO I'D
JONES. JONES I. LEIVA MIN. MAN
I KNEW MEN HIRED NEWMAN HI A
CHILL ABODE HI THE CHOKE GUIDE
HAN. BILL HAS NINE VOTES WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SIR. NEXT
ITEM ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN SEVEN
MEMBER SMITH WELCOME SIR YOU
HAVE ONE BILL TO PRESENT TODAY
IT'S A B. NINE ONE THREE PLEASE
PROCEED IN READING THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB NINE ONE
THREE UPDATES AND CLARIFIES THE
COLLATERAL RECOVERY ACT IN THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE.
TO REFLECT CURRENT PRACTICES
THE BILL ALSO UPDATES HOW THE
NOTICE OF SEIZURE OR THE
INVENTORY OF PERSONAL EFFECTS
MAY BE DELIVERED TO THE DEBTOR
TO REFLECT CURRENT BUSINESS
PRACTICES BY AUTHORIZING THE
NOTICE TO BE. DELIVERED BY
EMAIL. THE MAJORITY OF THE
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL PASSED
THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY
UNANIMOUSLY LAST YEAR. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO THE
SHORTENED SCHEDULE AND LIMITED
HEARING DID NOT MAKE IT INTO
THE FINAL PRODUCT IN THE SENATE.
A. B. NINE ONE THREE PASSED OUT
OF THE ASSEMBLY UNANIMOUSLY AND
IT HAS NO OPPOSITION. I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. I HAVE
G. V. AIRS IN JOE COLLINS
AVAILABLE REMOTELY TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATIONS OF LIGHT LICENSED
RE POSSESSORS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AS WE MOVE ON TO TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF YOUR YOUR MANAGER I
WILL NOTE THAT IT ENJOYS.
SUPPORT SUPPORT RECOMMENDATIONS
BOTH SIDES SO IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME I WOULD ASK THE
WITNESSES TO TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION WITH THE REMARKS.
THE GENTLEMAN YOU MAY PROCEED
WITH THIS IS. VERY BRIEFLY THIS
IS JEANNIE ERRORS OF GENERAL
RIVERS CONSULTING REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LICENSED REPOSSESSIONS. AND I'M
GLAD TO SPEAK ON THIS FINAL
BILL OF THE FINAL SCHEDULE BILL
WOULD- YOU KNOW THE COMMITTEE
THIS YEAR. FIRST OF ALL I WANT
TO SALUTE YOUR EXCELLENT
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
TREMENDOUS WORK. NOT ONLY TO
THIS HEARING BUT- THROUGHOUT-
THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF THEIR
WORK THANK YOU GENERAL ROSS AND
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH'S FOR
OFFERING THE BAIL WE ARE THE
SPONSORS- THE EIGHTY NINE
THIRTEEN. AND WE HAVE- WE HAVE
PUT THIS BILL FORWARD AND IN
ORDER TO- IN ORDER TO UPDATE
AND CLARIFY THE COLLATERAL
COVERAGE ACT. AND THE OUTDATED
DEFINITIONS OF THE ACT WHICH
LEADS TO CONFUSION. YOU AN
COMPLEX APPROACH IN THE REVERSE
INDUSTRY. APPLICATIONS NEED TO
BE MADE SO THAT CONSUMERS ARE
PROTECTED AND THAT THE
PROFESSION IS ABLE TO
EFFICIENTLY. AND EFFECTIVELY
OPERATE. UNDER FOR ANY
QUESTIONS ON THE BILL- OR- OR
ON THE RECENT AMENDMENTS I HAVE
WITH ME JOE COLLINS. FROM
CALABAR TO TESTIFY ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. A GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER SPEAKER- PHIL
COLLINS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LIFE VESSELS.
AND I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE.
GULF IN THE MIDDLE. THE NEW
TECHNICAL. QUESTION BUT ONE
THAT. THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
WILL NOT DOUBT TURNED TWENTY
SUPPORT WHEN THIS IS IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NO WITNESSES
THERE WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE A WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
ONE THREE. I SEE NO WITNESSES
THERE LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE WE
WILL BEGIN THE MEASURE ASSEMBLY
BILL. NINE ONE THREE. FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. SURE NO
ONE IS SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU LET'S FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES FIRST
IN THE GALLERY SEEING NO
WITNESSES THERE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO ASSEMBLY BILL NINE ONE
THREE. I SEE NO WITNESSES
WAITING THERE THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE ONE THREE AND WE WILL HEAR
FROM THEM. FOR THOSE OF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE. ONE ZERO. WE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK THE PREVIOUS
WHAT TO BE THEIR PHONE NOT.
THAT YOU'RE KNOWN AS SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK
YOU LET'S BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
REGARDING THIS MEASURE- CENTER
THOUGH I MOVED THE BILL. THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
HER TADO. I SEE NO OTHER MIKES
UP SO SIMPLY MEMBER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR LIVE-
THE- MOTION IT'S BEEN MADE BY
SENATOR TITLE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE IT IN FIFTEEN EIGHTY
NINE THIRTEEN DO YOU PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ROSS. ROSS I
MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S I ARCH
ALETTA. ARCHULETA ID'S BECKER.
BECKER I DIED. DONNA HI EIGHT
MIN HEY MAN I HEARD TADO HER
TADO I'D JONES. JONES I BELIEVE
THAT MEN. MAIN I KNEW MAN NEW
MAN I I'D SHOW ABODE UNTIL
ABOUT IPN. THE MEASURE HAS
ELEVEN VOTES BY MY COUNT WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. LET'S NOW TURN TO THE-
BUT- YEAH LET'S TURN TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. IS THERE A
MOTION OR SEARCH A LITTLE MOVES
THE CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEM SIX A. B.
FIFTEEN SEVENTY THREE ROSS NINE
ROSS I AM MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S
I ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA IBEATS
BACKER. BACKER I. DODD. DOT I.
EIGHTY MILLION SEGMENT I HER
TADO HER TADO I'D JONES JONES
I. LEIVA. MAN. MAIN HI NEWMAN
NEWMAN I A SHOW ABOUT OKAY. A
SHOW ABOUT IPN. CAN SCIENCE CAN
I THE- MEASURE HAS TWELVE VOTES
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. BE READY.
LET'S
OPEN THE ROLE. PERHAPS THE
MEMBERS MEMBERS ARE GOING TO GO
IN THE ORDER THAT WE TOOK THE
BILLS UP AND THEN WE HEARD THEM
SAY SO STARTING WITH FILE ITEM
TO AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO BY
MISTER BLOOM CURRENT VOTE NINE
TO ZERO BEATS HER TADO. HER
TADO I'D LEAVE US BUT SHOW
ABODE A CHOKE IPN. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS. ELEVEN TO TWO. WELL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN. WHAT ELEVEN
DAYS ZERO SKEWS ME. ALL THE
ROLE OPEN NEXT FILE ITEM FOR A
B. TWELVE TWENTY TWO. BY MISTER
CHAN ARCH ALETTA AT CRUDE BUT
SEVEN TWO ZERO ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D BEAT. AIKMAN HI
ADNAN I HER TADO- TATO HI LISA
A CHILL ABODE INTO A BOAT IPN.
VITAL LEVIN DOES ZERO OR HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN. FILE ITEM FIVE
AB NINE FIFTEEN BY MR QIU
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT TWO ZERO
BEATS. EGGMAN A MAN I HER TADO
FURTADO HI LISA BUT SHOW BOGUS
I CHOSE A BOW GUY. CURRENT VOTE
ELEVEN DOES ZERO OR HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN. VIOLATED EIGHT AB
TEN THIRTY SIX THIS IS MR
GARCIA'S SPELL BAIT. BOTH SORRY
EXCUSE ME THE CURRENT LOTUS
EIGHT TWO ZERO EIGHT. EIGHT MEN.
EIGHT MEN I HER TADO FURTADO HI
LISA IT SHOWED IT SHOWED BOTH I
CAN. THE CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN
TWO ZERO ALL THE ROLE OPEN.
FAIL ITEMS SEVEN EIGHTY TWO TWO
FOUR BY MR DAILY CURRENT VOTE
FIVE TO ZERO MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ NO FAITH EIGHT MEN.
HER TADO. HER TADO HI JONES
JONES I. LEIVA MAY IN A SHOW OF
BOGUE. THAT SHOW A BOGUS IPN.
VOTE EIGHT TO ONE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR. PHYLUM. NINE
EIGHTY SIX FIFTY ONE BY MISTER
GIBSON CURRENT VOTE EIGHT TWO
ZERO BEATS. DAUGHTER DOT HI HER
TADO. HER TADO I'D JONES JONES
I LEAVE A PATROL BOAT. A SHOW
ABOUT A GUY. VOTE TWELVE ZERO
OR HOLD THE ROLE OPEN. FILE
ITEM. TEN EIGHTY TWO EIGHT SIX
BUSINESS CONSULTANTS BILL
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN TO ONE BEAT.
EGG MAN. HER TADO. HER TADO I'D
JONES JONES NO LEAVE US BUT
SHOW A BOGUS. CURRENT VOTE.
EIGHT TO HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR.
1-311-801-4404 MR LEE'S MILL
ROAD EIGHT TWO ZERO MELINDA'S.
BEATS DODD. DODD HI JONES JONES
NO LLEVA BUT SHOW A BOGUS. BUT
SHOW A BOAT HI CURRENT VOTE TEN
TO ONE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN.
PHYLUM TWELVE EIGHTY TEN
FIFTEEN RUBIO MELINDA'S HOOKER
VOTE EXCUSE ME CURRENT VOTE TEN
TWO ZERO MELINDA'S MELINDA'S HI
BEATS. JONES JONES I LEAVE US.
CURRENT VOTE TWELVE ZERO WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN. FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN AB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
RUBIO CURRENT VOTE TEN TWO ZERO
MELINDA'S. MELENDEZ HI BEATS.
EGGMAN. EIGHT MEN HI LEAVE A-
VOTE TWELVE ZERO WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN. FALLON IN FOURTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR ZERO SEVEN SOLACE
CURRENT VOTE NINE TWO ZERO
MELINDA'S MELINDA'S IBEATS.
EGGMAN. EIGHT MEN HI LLEVA. CAN.
VOTE LEVIN THE ZERO OR HOLD THE
MATTER OPEN. FAT LATE IN.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY NINE THIRTEEN.
SMITH CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN TWO
ZERO BEATS. LLEVA CAN. CURRENT
VOTER LEVIN ZERO OR HOLD THE
MATTER OVER. CONSENT FILE ITEMS
SIX AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY THREE
CURRENT VOTE TWELVE TWO ZERO
BEATS. LEAVE A. THE FIRM VOTE
TWELVE ZERO WILL HOLD THE
MATTER OPEN. THE PROBLEM.
RIGHT
NOW. YEAH. YEAH. RIGHT. YEAH-
YEAH THE OTHER. YEAH. YEAH.
THE.
OKAY THERE. YOUR.
WE. LET'S
OPEN THE ROLE FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. PHYLUM TO AB TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN
TWO ZERO BEATS. LLEVA HI LEAVE
AT FIVE PM RIGHT HERE IN I-
INVOKES THIRTEEN ZERO THAT
MATTER IS OUT. FILE ITEM FOR A
B. TWELVE TWENTY TWO CURRENT
VOTE ELEVEN TWO ZERO BEATS.
LLEVA FIVE LEAVE A I'D HAND BY
CAN I- INVOKE THIRTEEN ZERO THE
MATTER IS OUT. FILE ITEM FIVE
AB NINE FIFTEEN CURRENT VOTE
ELEVEN TWO ZERO BEEPS LLEVA HI
LEAVE A IPN HI CAN I BURN BOOKS
THIRTEEN ZERO THE MATTERS OF.
FAIL ITEMS EIGHT EIGHTY TEN
THIRTY SIX CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN
TWO ZERO BEATS LLEVA HI LEAVE A
IPN. THIS IS TEN THIRTY SIX HI
CAN I. BIRBAL THIRTEEN ZERO THE
MATTERS OF. FAIL ITEMS SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO TWO FOUR CURRENT
VOTE EIGHT TO ONE EIGHTH. EIGHT
MEN LLEVA FIVE LISA HI MAN HAND.
CURRENT VOTE NINETY ONE THE
MATTER IS OUT. FILE. NINE
EIGHTY SIX FIFTY ONE CURRENT
VOTE TWELVE TWO ZERO BEATS
LLEVA HI LEAVE AT. FIVE
THIRTEEN ZERO THE MATTER IS A-
FINALLY I'M TEN EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY SIX CURRENT VOTE EIGHT
TWO TWO. BEATS EIGHT MEN LLEVA
HI LEAVE A HI BUT SHOW A BOGE.
BIRD NINE TWO TWO THE MATTER IS
OUT. EIGHTY FOURTEEN FORTY FOUR
CURRENT BIG TEN TO ONE
MELINDA'S. BEATS LLEVA FIVE
LEAVE A I'D- CURRENT VOTE LEVIN
TO ONE THE MATTER IS OUT. FILE
ITEM. TWELVE EIGHTY TEN FIFTEEN
CURRENT VOTE TWELVE TWO ZERO
BEATS LLEVA HI LEAVE A I'D
HEARD ABOUT THIRTEEN ZERO THE
MATTER IS A- FAIL ITEMS
THIRTEEN AB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
CURRENT VOTE TWELVE TWO ZERO.
BEATS LLEVA HI LEAVE US I HEARD
BOTH THIRTEEN ZERO THE MATTER
IS OUT. FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR ZERO SEVEN CURRENT
VOTE ELEVEN TWO ZERO BEATS
LLEVA HI LEAVE A IPN BY HAND I
HEARD BOTH THIRTEEN ZERO THE
MATTER IS OUT. FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN EIGHTY NINE THIRTEEN
CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN TWO ZERO
FAITH. LLEVA HI LEAVE AT IPN
ALL RIGHT HERE AND I- INVOKE
THIRTEEN ZERO MATTERS- CONSENT
FILE ITEM SIX EIGHTY FIFTEEN
SEVENTY THREE BAIT. LEAVE AT
ALL LEAVE A I- VOTE THIRTEEN
ZERO THE MATTER IS OUT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. RICHARD YEAH
OKAY THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OR PLEASE VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE CERTAINLY
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA FOR TODAY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. IS IT YOUR.